Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, warum liegt hier eigentlich Schnee rum?
Warum hast du eine Maske auf?
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertundachtzig vom achten Februar zwanzig einundzwanzig, ein Montag. Ja, in der Früh sind wir dabei und ähm
Ja, jetzt müssen wir auch Masken tragen beim Podcasten, denn sonst äh wird das halt alles nix.
Rein.
Jetzt schnait's rein und wir können ja jetzt auch nicht riskieren, dass sich über die Ausstrahlung des Podcasts noch weitere Leute mit äh interessanten Ideen infizierten oder so.
Aber äh das wird gefährlich, weil wir haben natürlich wieder einen äh Gast mit ganz besonders äh interessanten Ideen.
Ja, sehr hochinfektiös.
Hochinfektiöse Ideen.
Die Julia, hallo Julia, Julia Reder, herzlich willkommen zurück in Lokbuch-Netzpolitik.
Hallo, schön, dass ich wieder dabei sein darf und ich infiziere natürlich niemanden mit guten Ideen. Sowas habe ich gar nicht.
Da haben wir andere Belege. Die Zahlen sprechen für sich, Julia.
Naja, wir äh werden mal schauen, wen wir hier äh angesteckt kriegen oder nicht. Vorher müssen wir noch ein paar gute Ideen, Infektiöse, gute Ideen aus dem Feedback zu den letzten beiden Sendungen besprechen. Ähm wir haben ja bei dem letzten Special mit.
Steini nicht das Feedback aus der Sendung davor behandelt, deswegen fange ich damit mal an. Wir haben eine,
wir haben damals ja damals sag ich schon also wir haben über die gesprochen wo es mit und diese,
Ja, diesen Teil Erfolg gehabt, was da die Durchsetzung der DSGVO angeht. Dazu hatte
kommentiert. Ich wollte ein Data Access Request für Cleview machen, aber dafür muss ich ein Foto von meinem Personalausweis, auf deren US-Server hochladen.
Sie versprechen mir das Foto später zu löschen, aber da frage ich mich natürlich, ob ich ausgerechnet Clear View vertrauen kann. Ähm,
wenn ich nur löschen und äh Widerspruch einlegen möchte, muss ich keinen Perso hochladen. Äh die Frage habe ich einfach mal an weitergeleitet, der das ganze Ding ja ausgelöst hat und er antwortete,
Hallo Ellen, ich habe nicht das Formular genutzt, sondern eine E-Mail an Privacy Requisit at Clivy AI geschrieben.
Meine Auskunftsanfrage wurde beantwortet, obwohl ich gar kein Foto meines Persos, sondern nur ein nicht hoch aufgelöstes Foto meines Gesichts,
angehängt hatte. Falls sie auf einer ID-Card bestehen, würde ich alles bis auf Foto und Namen schmerzen,
und die Auflösung runterschrauben. Leider kann man nicht darauf vertrauen, dass Clever A die eingesandten Bilder auch wieder löscht, meine Auskunftsanfrage wurde im Februar zwanzig zwanzig beantwortet, da hieß es auch die,
Im Mai zwanzig zwanzig. Er holt erhältlich, ungefragt eine weitere Antwort,
Und da war das von mir eingesandte Suchbild mit dabei. Ähm dann hat er noch einen Link, wo der Ablauf seiner
Abfrage mit dabei ist. Äh ich kann noch ergänzen, ich äh habe auf Reisen auch regelmäßig die Anforderungen erlebt in vielleicht
nichteuropäischen Ländern, dass sich eine Passkopie an äh bringen musste. In einigen Ländern gibt's das auch tatsächlich als gesetzliche Anforderung, dass Passkopien von den,
äh beherbergten Personen eingesammelt werden.
Ich habe dann immer auch eine spezifisch quasi über diesen Scan des Passes halt äh so Querfett drüber geschrieben als Watermark zu welchem Zweck,
Kopie angefertigt wurde, äh um damit ein bisschen zu vermeiden, dass diese Kopie halt dann Blanko an anderer Stelle verwendet wird, um sich als ich zu authentifizieren. Auch das sicherlich keine,
kein todsichere Möglichkeit, aber eben alles Möglichkeiten hier äh zumindest den Missbrauch zu weiter einzuschränken.
Zu der ähm,
Sendung mit Steini haben wir auch relativ viel Feedback bekommen und da gab es äh eine Reihe an Kommentare. Ich habe jetzt mal eine Auswahl davon verlinkt, die mehr oder weniger, würde ich sagen, von ähm Lehrerinnen und Lehrern kamen.
Oder äh Leuten, die an Universitäten arbeiten.
Die also so sinngemäß sagten, so ich fasse das jetzt mal so zusammen, wir brauchen jetzt digitalen Unterricht, wir haben jetzt einen Notstand,
und ähm entsprechend lasse ich mich nicht als lehrende Person dafür irgendwie,
Ja, zurecht weisen, wenn ich jetzt hier auf funktionierende Infrastruktur von Privatanbietern, wie Zoom oder Microsoft Teams zurückgreife. Und äh da würde ich einfach mal zu sagen,
Ja, natürlich nicht. Natürlich wird jetzt nicht der einzelnen Lehrerinnen einen Vorwurf gemacht, die ähm im im Prinzip im Rahmen eines rechtfertigenden Notstands,
hier auf ein ein solches System zurückgreifen muss. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das äh die intendierte,
Aussage war von Steini. Allerdings muss jetzt kommt meine Meinung dazu, ne? Dieser rechtfertigende Notstand ist jetzt bald ein Jahr alt und da könnte man sich ja mal drum kümmern. Insofern würde ich sagen, unsere Aussage ist viel mehr,
die das.
Relativ offensichtlich in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten hier versäumt wurde, eine Infrastruktur aufzubauen und außerdem dieser Notstand jetzt auch lange genug anhält, dass man,
diese Infrastruktur jetzt wenigstens auch mal selber hätte aufbauen können. Und das äh war Steini eben hier berichtet für das Land Berlin, dass da eben.
Einerseits die diese Big Globutton Infrastruktur äh bereitstellen und zweitens, das haben wir hier gar nicht so großartig erzählt, äh sie auch bei dem
des äh Lernraum Berlins geholfen haben. Äh das zeigt ja so ein bisschen, dass dass das eben auch Schule macht. Andererseits,
denke ich, dass nicht das nachhaltige Konzept sein kann, wenn hier Privatpersonen helfen müssen, die Geschichte mit dem Lernraum Berlin war so, das war halt eine monolithische Mode-Infrastruktur für alle Schulen in Berlin.
Und wenn dann morgens um acht alle Schülerinnen aller Schulen in Berlin darauf zugreifen wollten, dann ist das Ding platt gegangen. Und das lag.
Tatsächlich am Ende, wie sich dann durch Analysen von InFarun äh herausstellte. Daran.
Dass dort eine bestimmte Tabelle in dem MySQL, auf die dieses Modell zurückgreift, nicht nicht so indiziert war, dass sie diese,
spezifische Abfrage schnell machen konnte. Ähm und mit einem Neubauen des Index für diese Tabelle konnten dann diese Performance Probleme,
signifikant verringert werden. Und,
Hintergrund ist in dem Fall natürlich okay, einerseits, das war halt ein weil Mode nicht damit
gerechnet hat, dass jemand ein monolithisches Model für ein komplettes Bundesland setzen würde. Äh und zweitens aber natürlich auch ein allgemeines Problem, wenn da
am Ende mit dem Pflegen dieser Instanz eine einzige Person betraut ist, die dann eben Hilfe von.
Ehrenamtlichen braucht, das deutet eben auf größere Missstände hin. Also niemand will einer einzelnen Lehrerin hier Vorwürfe machen. Ich denke, das ist ein Problem, wo der äh Fisch vom Kopf stinkt.
Und ich würde aber schon sagen, dass es kein.
Kein wünschenswerter Zustand ist, wenn eine Lehrerin sich zwanzig im im Februar zwanzig einundzwanzig immer noch im Prinzip auf einen Notstand berufen muss, wenn sie jetzt hier auf äh Privatanbieter Infrastruktur ausweichen muss.
Siehst du das anders, Julia?
Nö, ich denke, das ist genau richtig. Also ich meine,
Letzten Endes ist es ja auch die Aufgabe, irgendwie des Staates des Gesetzgebers da vernünftige Regeln zu schaffen und nicht die Aufgabe von einzelnen Lehrerinnen und Lehrern da die vernünftige Lösung zu finden.
Richtig, die kriegen ja auch, also die kriegen ja auch ein Schulgebäude äh ein Klassenzimmer und Kreide gestellt und da muss ich, denke ich mal, entsprechend äh eine Anpassung äh dann eben auch stattfinden, wenn sich die Anforderungen an den Unterricht ändern.
Ja, also viele Schulen haben ja anscheinend noch nicht mal ein Süßatmen, also.
Ja, nö, haben die nicht.
Für was denn auch? Gab ja nichts zu administrieren.
Das heißt, wir haben ein Hennerei Hahnproblem. Nicht nur ein Hennerei-Problem.
OK dann gab es noch relativ ausführliches Feedback zu dieser ganzen Geschichte mit und auch sehr langer Kommentar von ist.
Ähm der hier einen spezifischen Aspekt nochmal anspricht. Ich kommentiere den mal auszuweisen. Es tut mir leid, dass ich den im Sinne der Zeit etwas kürze. Äh und zwar geht es darum, dass ja ähm.
So Unternehmen wie Robin Hood und Trade Republik
also diese Trading Apps Trading Plattform äh zeitweise den Handel mit der Gamestop-Aktie ausgesetzt haben. So und dazu kommentiert Slaty. Daniel meinte, die hätten diese,
Aktien zeitweise vom Handel ausgeschlossen. Diese Umschreibung trifft aber das, was tatsächlich stattfanden nur ungenügend.
Denn man denkt dabei an einen temporären Handelsstopp anhand großer Volatilität und das ist an der Börse etwas, was fast
täglich bei irgendwelchen Aktien zu beobachten ist und bei Überschreitungen bestimmter Volatilitätsschwellen automatisiert stattfindet. Also wenn die Aktie viel zu sehr wackelt,
dann wird sie automatisch vom Handel.
Ausgeschlossen. Diese Events sind auch vollkommen harmlos und insofern fair, als dass sie alle Marktteilnehmer.
Gleichermaßen betreffen. Aber das, was sich da bei Gamestop und Konsorten abspielte,
war etwas völlig anderes, denn effektiv wurde dann nur das weitere Kaufen verhindert, nicht
das Verkaufen und das auch nur bei bestimmten Brokern und nicht bei allen, wie das bei regulären Handelspausen der Fall ist.
Es war also sozusagen ein einseitiger Handelsausschuss, der nur bestimmte Broker beziehungsweise deren Kunden betraf. Und das kommt eine Art Marktmanipulation gleich, die eigentlich nicht vorgesehen ist.
Und für die es auch meines Wissens,
keine historischen Präzedenzen gibt. Robin Hood und Co haben nicht nur Lithrally, sondern ganz praktisch und tatsächlich den Beitrag in ihrer App ausgegraut, den Sale-Button aber aktiv gelassen.
Darauf wurden die Beschränkungen teilweise wieder zurückgenommen, aber nur insofern, als das Limits eingezogen wurden, so dass Kunden zum Beispiel im Fall Robin Hood nur noch erst fünf, dann drei und dann irgendwann nur noch eine,
Gamestop-Aktie besitzen durften. So, er geht jetzt noch sehr viel weiter darauf ein, dass das ähm
welche Konsequenzen das hat auch
was die eigene Struktur von Robin Hood und so weiter angeht, dafür verweise ich auf den Kommentar, der, wie gesagt, eine sehr wichtige äh Ergänzung ist und er sagt, das wird noch einmal hochspannend, wenn hier die.
SEC ermittelt und ein paar Urspreite, äh paar Urteile gesprochen werden.
Äh denn da werden die Grundregeln des freien Marktes und der Börsenregeln am Ende verhandelt. Also das fand ich einen sehr wichtigen Hintergrund, den ich als Ergänzung hier nochmal,
zitieren wollte und dann gab's noch eine andere finde ich sehr gute Ergänzung, eine sehr gute Idee.
Von hier den falschen Kommentar verlinkt, der im Prinzip sagt, na ja, das Shorten.
Hat ja noch ein weiteres Problem, denn ähm es, ah ja, da ist es, das ist der Kommentar von.
Inne Rand. Was mir im Podcast gefehlt hat, ist, dass das an sich bereits eine Marktverzerrung darstellt. Auch wenn man
niemandem davon erzählt. Der Aktienkurs entsteht durch Angebot und Nachfrage. Ist das Angebot größer als die Nachfrage einer Aktie, dann wird diese im Kurs tendenziell fallen. Shorten,
Macht aber genau das, es erzeugt ein künstliches Angebot, welches es eigentlich nicht gibt.
Der Eigentümer der Aktie hat hier nicht vor, diese zu verkaufen und drückt alleine dadurch den Kurs. Also, ne,
Im Prinzip gibt's die Aktie überhaupt nicht im Angebot. Jetzt gehen aber die Short dahin, leihen sich die und verkaufen die geliehenen, erzeugen also ein Angebot.
Das eigentlich nicht vorhanden ist und da durch dieses Überangebot fällt dann also auch,
Aktie im Kurs. Den umgekehrten Fall haben wir durch das Hebeln. Hier wird eine Nachfrage erzeugt, die es eigentlich nicht gibt. Schließlich hat der Käufer das Geld
gar nicht und er muss die Aktie wieder verkaufen, um den Kredit zu tilgen. Beides klingt irgendwie nicht richtig, etwas verkaufen, das einem nicht gehört, ähm.
Oder eine Kapitalanlage mit Geld kaufen, das man nicht hat. Das heißt, dadurch wird wenig erreicht. In erster Linie werden Möglichkeiten zum Zocken geschaffen und,
genau dadurch bringt man jede Menge Instabilität in das System. Wenn gehebelt wurde und die Kurse fallen, müssen viele verkaufen, was erst recht einen Kurssturz auslöst. Was sich das Shirt in ausgelöst wird,
die Kurse steigen konnte man dann eben gerade beobachten. Warum ist das eigentlich erlaubt? Äh auch hier gibt's eine längere Antwort von äh die,
und auch in unserer kurzen Clubhaus-Runde dazu hatte Daniel das nochmal erklärt, naja du kannst es im Prinzip nicht verbieten und es gibt,
tatsächlich auch legitime Anwendungsfälle,
äh zum Beispiel Futures oder Leerverkäufe zu machen. Besonders toll findet's aber niemand und äh deswegen finde ich diese Ergänzung, dass allein das selber hier schon,
eben auch eine Verzerrung ist, durchaus eine äh wichtige inhaltliche Ergänzung.
Womit wir bei einer weiteren Wahl Daniel hatte in der Sendung gesagt äh ich verstehe nicht, warum man die äh Impfterminvergabe nicht einfach an Leute ausgegeben hat, die sich mit so etwas auskennen und hat Eventim als einen der großen Ticketverkäufer,
angegeben, ja äh Ergänzung, ja gibt's, wurde auch schon gemacht in Schleswig-Holstein hat man Eventim.
Betraut und es scheint wohl auch äh ja besser funktioniert zu haben, als äh woanders.
Und dann gab's noch einen äh eine Ergänzung von Chantal, einer niedersächsischen Finanzbeamtin, die sagt.
Sie arbeitet seit langem mit einem Lynoxsystem und äh hofft, dass das auch so bleibt. Benennt dann irgendwie Open Office, Wanderbird.
Firefox und sagt, dass sie damit relativ gute Erfahrungen hat und sich natürlich wundert, dass alle immer nur von wenn solche Projekte mal äh stattfinden, von den negativen äh.
Diskutieren und jetzt irgendwie, sage ich mal, dass es in Niedersachsen seit sehr langer Zeit ziemlich problemlos funktioniert.
Dass darüber nicht berichtet wird. Es gibt aber auch ein paar Probleme, gerade äh die Homeoffice Quote kriegen sie nicht vernünftig hin. Und das wird nur langsam verbessert,
da stellt sich aber natürlich die Frage, hängt das jetzt an? Linox äh oder hängt das vielleicht an anderen Sachen.
Fand ich auch mal ein schönes Feedback, dass natürlich eher von Problemen berichtet wird als von erfolgreichen Lösungen.
Da damit machen wir jetzt weiter. Wir sprechen nämlich jetzt über Probleme statt erfolgreiche Lösungen und zwar zur Urheberrechtsreform.
Das war die perfekte Überleitung, also schöner hätte man's eigentlich kaum sagen können.
Hast du eigentlich noch Lust über die Urwahlrechtsreform zu sprechen?
Also es ist schon ein bisschen anders als vor zwei Jahren, als die großen Proteste waren. Da war irgendwie die Dramaphase und jetzt sind wir so bei Tragekomödie angekommen, glaube ich,
Aber äh es macht mir natürlich immer noch Spaß, äh zu sagen, dass ich das ja alles schon immer gesagt habe.
Vielleicht müssen wir, äh weil du gerade schon sagst, dass ein paar Jahre oder längere Zeit jetzt schon her ist, nochmal kurz deine Rolle beleuchten, du warst in.
Im EU Parlament als du warst Mitglied des EU Parlamentes als Vertreterin der Piratenpartei, aus der du aber.
Dann noch kurz vor Ende deines Mandats ausgetreten bist, wenn ich mich nicht recht täusche.
Genau und äh ja im Europaparlament war ich ähm an den Verhandlungen für die Urheberrechtsreform beteiligt.
Für die Grünen Eva Fraktion mit denen die Piraten ja auch schon seit langer Zeit im Europaparlament zusammenarbeiten, das heißt ich hab an diesen ganzen ähm.
Verhandlungsrunden, hinter verschlossenen Türen teilgenommen und dann letzten Endes auch den öffentlichen Protest gegen diese Richtlinie so mit angeleitet, ähm weil ich eben,
befürchtet habe, dass diese Reform, so wie sie da verabschiedet wurde, nicht umsetzbar ist, beziehungsweise zu großen Kollateralschäden führen wird.
Und ja, die bei den Kollateralschäden sind wir jetzt sozusagen.
Hast dich dann äh entschieden ähm nicht weiter in äh nicht weiter zu kandidieren. Danke mal, du hättest jetzt eine.
Relativ große Sicherheit gehabt, wiedergewählt zu werden aufgrund deiner.
Bekanntheit im deutschen Bereich und aufgrund deiner besonderen Rolle für die Piratenpartei, aber das hast du dich gezielt entschieden nicht zu machen, ne? Du bist jetzt bei der du wolltest in diesem,
Wie hast du es damals gesagt? Du wolltest irgendwie in diesem Apparat nicht als Berufspolitikerin enden?
Genau, also äh das Europaparlament ist ja jetzt mit Urheberrecht erstmal fertig. Das heißt also, ich hätte natürlich
wieder kandidieren können und mir sozusagen ein neues Thema suchen können
Aber ich bin ja nicht äh in die Politik gegangen, um Politikerin zu werden, sondern um das Urheberrecht zu reformieren. Und da spielt die Musik inzwischen eben in Deutschland, weil das Ganze umgesetzt werden muss. Und ja, ich habe mich dann,
der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte angeschlossen, die sich ja äh vor allen Dingen mit der Durchsetzung der Grundrechte vor Gericht,
beschäftigt, weil ich eben glaube, dass Deutschland diese Reform eigentlich gar nicht,
so wirklich grundrechtsfreundlich umsetzen kann, denn dafür ist die europäische Vorlage schon zu schlecht. Also das heißt, ich ähm bringe mich jetzt natürlich in die Debatte über die Umsetzung in Deutschland ein. Aber ich glaube, dass äh egal, was es,
was dabei rauskommen wird, ist am Ende sicherlich zu Gerichtsverfahren kommen wird, wo die Grenzen von Uploadfiltern, Einschränkungen der Meinungsfreiheit und so weiter werden austariert,
werden müssen und da hoffe ich natürlich ähm über die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte dran mitwirken zu können, damit die Grundrechte dabei eben nicht unter die Räder kommen.
Mit Uploadfilter, wir haben noch von der CDU, SPD-Koalition ganz klar gesagt bekommen, dass Uploadfilter nicht kommen werden, weil die Richtlinie das überhaupt nicht fordern würde.
Ja, stimmt, also ähm die SPD war da zumindest insofern ein bisschen schlauer, dass sie schon vor zwei Jahren,
mit dem Zurückrudern angefangen haben und gesagt haben wir wollen versuchen Upload-Filter,
weitgehend zu verhindern, während die CDU sich halt hingestellt hat und gesagt hat, vertraut auf unser Wort, Uploadfilter wird es mit uns nicht geben. Und jetzt eben
mit mit dem Zurückrudern zwei Jahre im Verzug sind. Also letzte Woche hat die Bundesregierung ihren Entwurf für die Umsetzung von Artikel siebzehn beschlossen,
Das heißt, jetzt äh geht das in den Bundestag und da hat die CDU dann eben schnell ihre Webseite geändert und ähm also erst haben sie den Artikel,
komplett offline genommen, wo drin stand, dass äh Uploadfilter nicht kommen werden. Und dann haben sie ihn doch wieder online gestellt nach dem äh bekannten Streusand-Effekt äh und haben geschrieben, ja leider konnten wir uns,
mit unserer, mit unseren Zielen nicht durchsetzen und wir mussten alle Kompromisse machen.
Gegenüber wählen. Sie sind die Regierenden.
Das hat auch einige von der SPD ziemlich sauer gemacht, weil natürlich gehören zum äh Regieren,
immer mindestens zwei oder vielleicht die CSU mischt auch noch mit aber es ist natürlich völlig klar, also weder die SPD noch die CDU hat jemals einen Umsetzungsvorschlag gemacht, äh der,
tatsächlich Uploadfilter verhindern würde, aber zumindest war der erste Entwurf vom letzten Sommer vom Justizministerium noch besser als das, was jetzt beschlossen wurde. Also das heißt, wenn die CDU äh erst in den Verhandlungen,
quasi die Uploadfilter schärfer stellt und sich danach hinsetzt und sagt, äh es war aber die SPD schuld, dann ist das schon extrem scheinheilig.
Hätten sie aber also am Ende sind sie ja dann gescheitert an auch der durch sie selber geschaffenen Realität. Oder wäre es möglich gewesen eine Urheberrechtsreform ohne Uploadfilter zu gestalten.
Theoretisch ja, praktisch wahrscheinlich nein. Also theoretisch ja, sage ich deshalb, weil,
die Plattform ja nur dann filtern müssen, wenn sie keine Lizenz haben oder wenn sie keine,
Erlaubnis haben, die Inhalte zu verwenden. Und das heißt also, einen Weg hätte es theoretisch gegeben, nämlich dass man per Gesetz alles erlaubt,
die Plattform verpflichtet, die den Verwertungsgesellschaften dafür eine Vergütung zu zahlen, also im Grunde genommen die Kulturflatrate,
hätte man sich dann immer noch drüber streiten können, ob das mit äh,
europäischem Recht in anderen Punkten übereinstimmt, aber das wäre, glaube ich, die einzige Möglichkeit, wo man auf Upload-Filter komplett verzichten könnte, wenn man halt per Gesetz dafür sorgt, dass die Plattform für alles eine Erlaubnis haben,
Hätte man machen können. Das war auch so mehr oder weniger der Vorschlag, den die CDU auf ihrer Webseite stehen hatte bis letzte Woche,
Aber ähm es gibt natürlich also massive Interessen innerhalb äh der Unterhaltungsindustrie, die das nicht wollen. Also zum Beispiel die Filmindustrie
ist ja völlig klar, dass die nicht damit einverstanden wären, wenn YouTube zwar ihn in Zukunft bezahlen muss, aber deshalb Kinofilme von Tag eins irgendwie,
auf YouTube abrufbar sind.
Also realistisch, also fernab jeder realität,
Vorstellung war das von vorneherein. Das war ja auch, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, immer dein Punkt, dass du äh primär die CDU immer gesagt hat, also das waren ja noch während der Verhandlung, wo dann äh
Axel Voss
zum Beispiel sagte so, nein, es brauchen keine man braucht keine Uploadfilter, die müssen nur aufpassen, dass sie dass man nichts hochladen kann, wofür man keine Lizenz hat, ja. Und du hast dann immer gesagt, das bedeutet Upload-Filter und er hat dann immer gesagt, Uploadfilter steht da aber nirgendwo.
Ja, das ist äh glaube ich eine ganz gute Zusammenfassung äh damals von der Diskussion. Es ist aber, glaube ich, auch noch ein kleines Stück absurder
also nicht nur kann man Artikel siebzehn eigentlich nicht ohne Uploadfilter umsetzen, eigentlich kann man Artikel siebzehn auch nicht mit Upload-Filtern umsetzen,
denn äh also es gab ja die großen Proteste und äh die EU hat also die EU-Kommission hat sich große Sorgen gemacht, dass Artikel siebzehn vielleicht am Ende abgelehnt wird. Das war ja auch sehr knapp im Europaparlament. Und deshalb haben,
Verhandlungsparteien in in diesen äh Trilog-Verhandlungen in letzter Minute auch noch einige Nutzerrechte mit reingeschrieben,
Und zwar steht im Artikel siebzehn drin, dass legale Inhalte nicht gesperrt werden dürfen.
Und zwar also da steht nicht irgendwie, dass sie systematisch nicht gesperrt werden dürfen oder dass sie nicht so oft gesperrt werden dürfen, sondern eigentlich steht da, es darf überhaupt nicht dazu kommen, dass legale Inhalte nicht verfügbar sind,
Und äh äh es gibt keinen Upload-Filter, der das kann. Das heißt also eigentlich,
ist eine Umsetzung mit Uploadfilter, genauso unmöglich wie eine Umsetzung ohne Upload-Filter. Und das ist natürlich irgendwie eine blöde Situation.
Die muss aber jetzt in nationaler Gesetzgebung gelöst werden, diese Situation.
Genau, also im Grunde genommen hat sich der EU-Gesetzgeber so aus der Affäre gestohlen und hat gesagt, ja wir wir,
Wir überlassen den Mitgliedsstaaten die Lösung, also wie man dafür sorgen kann, dass alle Urheberrechtsverletzungen verschwinden und alle legalen Inhalte online bleiben,
und ähm also man muss der Bundesregierung zumindest zugute halten, dass sie es versucht,
Also perfekt funktioniert das natürlich nicht und es gibt andere Länder, wie zum Beispiel Frankreich, die einfach sagen,
ist uns egal, dass da steht, dass legale Inhalte nicht gesperrt werden dürfen, wir sperren einfach trotzdem alles,
und wir erhalten Zitat oder irgendeine andere legale Nutzung hat, der kann sich halt beschweren und dann wird's nachträglich wieder freigeschaltet. Aber,
also so eine Umsetzung widerspricht ganz offensichtlich nicht nur dem Wortlaut von Artikel siebzehn, sondern auch den Grundrechten
Also Deutschland versucht zumindest irgendwie beiden Anforderungen irgendwie gerecht zu werden. Aber das Problem ist halt äh die Uploadfilter sind nicht besonders intelligent. Also die können nicht,
feststellen, was ist eine Parodie, was ist ein Zitat oder auch nur sicher sein, wer überhaupt der echte Rechteinhaber ist und so. Und ähm.
Der Vorschlag, den sie deshalb gemacht haben, basiert im Grunde darauf, dass man technische Schwellenwerte definiert.
Quasi sagen sollen, also wenn ein Upload diese Eigenschaften hat, die irgendwie quantitativ messbar sind, dann ist er mutmaßlich erlaubt,
weil quasi die Wahrscheinlichkeit zu hoch ist, dass es sich um ein Zitat handelt, also zum Beispiel wenn der Ausschnitt aus einem fremden Werk sehr kurz ist und irgendwie mit anderen Inhalten kombiniert wird,
und solche mutmaßlich erlaubten Inhalte dürfen nicht automatisch gesperrt werden,
ursprünglich stand auch mal in dem ersten Entwurf, die sollen legalisiert werden, das wär irgendwie sehr schön gewesen, dann hätten,
zumindest auch noch irgendwas von dieser Reform. Das haben sie jetzt leider äh wieder rausverhandelt. Ähm wahrscheinlich auf Druck auch der Industrie. Also das heißt, so kurze Ausschnitte sind nicht
per se legal, aber sie dürfen halt nicht vollautomatisch durch Uploadfilter gesperrt werden, sondern.
Das heißt noch nicht einmal das haben wir bekommen, weil das war ja eigentlich, das war doch eigentlich immer so der der ja das kleine bisschen, das das war ja schon ganz mickrig, ne, dass man dann sagte, hier ähm.
Was war, da waren ja auch so Zeichenmengen zur Diskussion, ne? Hundertvierzig oder hundertsechzig Zeichen oder was war das?
Ja, also es waren ursprünglich mal tausend Zeichen, die legal äh sein sollten. Und jetzt sind es hundertsechzig Zeichen
die nicht mal legal sind, sondern die nur von der automatischen Sperrung ausgenommen sind. Aber der Witz ist, allein der Name der Urheberrechtsrichtlinie ist zweihundertzwanzig Zeichen dank,
Also.
Äh
Ich glaube, wer Upload-Filter so scharf schaltet, dass irgendwie hundertsechzig Zeichen Textautomatisch gesperrt werden, der hat ganz andere Probleme als irgendwie,
die Frage ob sich da um Zitat handelt, also das wird einfach zu krassen führen,
einfach zufällig irgendwelche Eigennamen verwendet werden, von Gesetzen, von komplizierten Institutionen oder was auch immer und das sieht so aus, als wäre da eine Urheberrechtsverletzung, dabei ist da gar nichts.
Was glaubst du denn, wer also wer hat denn Interesse, dass so kurz zu halten, weil es ja jetzt schon ja, es ist wirklich schwer.
Zu argumentieren, dass irgendwie etwas, was ja, man kann da ja bei hundertsechzig Zeichen der bietet sich halt der Vergleich zu SMS an, die auf hundertvierzig Zeichen limitiert war, was oder die hundertsechzig? Herrje
Tim, wie lange durfte eine SMS sein? Du warst doch damals im Internet.
Das waren hundertvierzig, oder? Das war ja auch der ursprüngliche Tweet.
Oder waren das hundertsechzig und deswegen sind's bei Twitter hundertvierzig.
Hundertsechzig, hundert genau, richtig, also dass da sozusagen noch ein bisschen Metadaten noch mit reinpasst. Hundertsechzig ist das alte SMS-Limit, hundertvierzig das ursprüngliche Tweetlimit, da sind wir jetzt bei zweihundertachtzig.
Okay, ja, dann äh also ich.
Ich sag mal so, man kann ja mal ein Ratespiel machen, wer irgendwie auf solche Ideen kommt. Also vielleicht könnt ihr euch ja an andere Urheberrechtsdebatten äh erinnern, wo irgendwie über einzelne Wörter oder einzelne Zeichen gestritten wurde.
Ähm.
Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverlage käme mir in den Sinn.
Also das ist auch ziemlich krass,
eigentlich ist das wieder so ein hausgemachtes, deutsches Problem, weil in der Urheberrechtsrichtlinie ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht vorgesehen,
dass der Artikel siebzehn, also dass die Uploadfilter überhaupt für das Leistungsschutzrecht gelten. Also eigentlich äh,
sollte das nur für das Urheberrecht gelten und so die alten Leistungsschutzrechte für Tonträger und so weiter. Und das ist leider in der deutschen Umsetzung nicht so. Also da hat man eh schon,
den Presseverlagen ein riesiges Geschenk gemacht, indem man sagt, ihr dürft Uploadfilter nutzen, aber ich meine, sorry, wenn man irgendwie dem Springer Verlag oder der VG Media, die jetzt irgendwie heißt, äh,
so ein Tool in die Hand gibt und sagt, ihr dürft sperren, dann wollen die natürlich, dass äh da äh dass das äh.
Auch so kleinteilig funktioniert, wie die sich das bei dem Leistungsschutzrecht vorstellen. Und da ging's ja immer darum, irgendwie einzelne Wörter zu zählen und als so eine Textzeichen, weil man alles so kleinteilig wie möglich kontrollieren will.
Okay, aber jetzt.
Haben wir also hier diese diese Presseverlage, die die weiterhin in der Lage sind, diese politische Auseinandersetzung so zu dominieren
ähm oder gab, also was ist aus den ganzen Leuten geworden, die sich da eingebracht haben, was ist aus den vielen Versprechen geworden? Das ist ja schon eine ähm,
schon einmaliger oder vielleicht auch nicht ein einmaliger Vorgang, aber zumindest ein einmaliger Vorgang, das bekannt wird, dass eine Partei so dermaßen ihre Position ändert, dass sie sogar irgendwelche Webseiten offline nehmen müssen, die ihnen irgendwie peinlich geworden sind.
Tja also.
Ich weiß nicht, ob einen das jetzt so total überraschen sollte, weil viele haben natürlich auch damals äh schon gesagt, dass dieser CDU-Vorschlag.
Für eine Umsetzung ohne Uploadfilter, dass das Augenwischerei ist. Ähm.
Insofern, ja, also äh ich glaube schon, dass äh die Presseverlage so zu fünfundneunzig Prozent das bekommen haben, was sie wollten in in diesem Regierungsentwurf,
und dass es bei anderen ähm Konflikten ein bisschen ausgewogener ist. Also zum Beispiel bei dem ganzen Bereich Musik,
Da gibt's irgendwie äh großes Gekloppe äh zwischen allen möglichen. Also inzwischen äh gibt's auch so offene Brandbriefe, wo die
die GEMA,
irgendwie als inkompetent darstellen und die GEMA dann zurückschreibt von wegen ohne uns würde es Artikel.
Geben, ihr undankbares Pack und äh also das heißt, alle streiten sich mit allen, niemand ist so richtig zufrieden. Ähm aber beim Bereich Text,
Ist es einfach radikal einseitig, zugunsten der Presseverlage umgesetzt worden. Also zum Beispiel die die äh Grenzwerte, die da jetzt vorgeschlagen sind für ähm.
Ton und Videoaufnahmen, da sollen fünfzehn Sekunden von der automatischen Sperrung ausgenommen sein. Das ist natürlich ähm.
Immer noch nicht.
So dass es dann überhaupt nicht zur Sperrung von legalen Inhalten kommen kann, weil natürlich kann auch ein legales Zitat länger sein als fünfzehn Sekunden, aber es ist trotzdem irgendwie noch.
Ja, also,
handhabbarer und es ist relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass es da einfach zu fauls Positives kommt, weil ähm also wenn man so in fünfzehn Sekunden Match hat, dann kann man sich zumindest relativ sicher sein, dass es sich da wirklich um dasselbe Video handelt,
während das halt bei fünfzehn äh bei hundertsechzig Zeichen Text noch nicht mal das sichergestellt ist. Also es sieht schon alles danach aus, als ob die Presseverlage immer noch ähm,
am längeren Hebel sitzen, wenn's um diese Verhandlung innerhalb der Bundesregierung geht.
Ich frage mich, wo die diesen Hebel her haben wollen. Ja, also okay, ich meine.
Na ja, dieses Jahr ist Bundestagswahl. Ähm.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch das, was irgendwie den Nutzerinnen und Nutzern zu Gute kommt, dass man zumindest so ein kleines bisschen Angst haben muss vor äh,
der Frage, wie das eigentlich so bei der Wählerschaft ankommt. Aber natürlich haben in einem Wahljahr auch die Presseverlage ganz besonders äh
Einfluss über Politikerinnen und Politiker, also ähm ich weiß nicht, äh in der, in der CDU.
Ist ja auch noch ungeklärt, wer irgendwie am Ende ähm Kanzlerkandidat werden soll und da spielen natürlich solche Dinge wie Beliebtheitszahlen in der Bevölkerung eine große Rolle. Und natürlich hat da auch die Berichterstattung einen großen Einfluss drauf.
Aber gerade wenn ich an äh ja Berichterstattung CDU, Internet denke, dann denke ich ja auch an,
Erstens, diese breite Protestkampagne gegen diese Urheberrechtsreform, die kam eben nicht von in Traditionellen,
Medien, die jetzt irgendwie große
Lobbyverbände unterhalten, sondern sie kam aus dem Netz und insbesondere in dem Kontext kam es ja dann auch zu so Sachen hier wie äh die Zerstörung der CDU, wo,
ne mal mediale journalistische Arbeit gemacht hat und gezeigt hat hier wie sieht's mit dieser,
Partei aus, also die müssten doch eigentlich auch gelernt haben, dass wenn sie öffentlich gut dastehen wollen, dass das im Zweifelsfall,
nicht nur von den Presseverlagen abhängt.
Ja, absolut, also deshalb ist auch, glaube ich, der Entwurf nicht ganz so schlecht, wie er hätte sein können,
Also außer halt, es geht irgendwie um die Interessen der Presseverlage. Dann ist es zu hundert Prozent einseitig. Es gibt durchaus ein paar ganz gute Vorschläge da drin, die es vorher nicht gab. Also zum Beispiel, dass es jetzt irgendwie,
Möglichkeiten geben soll gegen falsche Copyright-Claims vorzugehen. Also das kommt ja immer mal wieder vor, auf YouTube oder so, dass irgendjemand einfach irgendwas klämt,
was ihnen überhaupt nicht gehört, also teilweise ist das auch irgendwie so ein Fernsehsender, claimt irgendwas, was äh äh eher in seiner Sendung gespielt hat, obwohl ähm,
Damit dann eigentlich das Original offline genommen wird. Also dagegen gibt's jetzt bestimmte Vorschläge, wie dagegen vorgegangen werden soll, werden soll. Und.
Ja, also ich meine, äh äh dass es dass es irgendwie in diesem Vorschlag Uploadfilter geben würde. Das war leider klar.
Aber ähm ich glaube schon, dass die Bundesregierung zumindest so ein Stück weit doch Angst hat, auch vor den Protesten der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer, nur eben nicht genug Angst
um sich dafür mit dem Presseverlagen anzuregen, äh anzulegen. Also die haben einfach nochmal äh.
Einfluss als alle anderen in der Politik. Also es hat, glaube ich, teilweise auch damit zu tun, dass die Leute in den Ministerien auch gar nicht mitkriegen, was auf YouTube läuft,
wenn es nicht irgendwie sechs Millionen Views hat. Also die kriegen morgens ihren Pressespiegel. Da wird ähm.
Die Berichterstattung über das Thema Urheberrecht in den Printmedien zusammengefasst, also da ist.
Wenn man Glück hat, sind reine Onlineveröffentlichungen von Zeitungen mit drin, aber alles, was auf Social Media passiert, schon mal nicht,
Und da haben die Presseverlage einfach über den Winter eine krasse Kampagne geschoben,
halt drin stand zum Beispiel irgendwie es gab so einen Artikel in der FAZ, der hieß die tausend Zeichen Enthauptung,
Also da haben sie quasi äh äh behauptet, dass man mit äh Presse überhaupt kein Geld mehr verdienen kann, wenn eben,
äh Übereinstimmung von tausend Zeichen nicht automatisch geblockt werden.
Diese Beiträge waren voll mit Lügen, also da wurde halt zum Beispiel behauptet, dass man dann irgendwie ganze Gedichte abdrucken dürfte und solche Sachen dabei äh steht in dem Entwurf eigentlich drin,
dass man sowieso nicht mehr als fünfzig Prozent eines Rentenwerkes übernehmen darf und solche Sachen. Ähm aber das hat natürlich einen großen Eindruck gemacht, glaube ich, äh in der Politik,
Weil, ja, FAZ ist da halt immer noch so ein Leitmedium, was auch in den Ministerien wahrgenommen wird.
Und bei Social Media, da merkt man's dann vielleicht erst, wenn's in die heiße Phase des Wahlkampfs geht.
Okay, das leuchtet ein. Wir waren gerade beim Lob. Also ich fand das gar nicht so äh ähm egal dieses Lob, weil die das,
Inhalte fälschlicherweise gesperrt werden. Da haben wir regelmäßig Fälle von und das ist genau genannt. Ich glaube bei äh,
Thilo Jung gab's kürzlich wieder so einen Fall, dass Inhalte von Jung und Naiv von einem Fernsehsender übernommen werden wurden
und dann deren automatisches Content Blocking den Originalinhalt offline genommen hat. Ähm in dem Fall ließ sich das sehr schnell klären, ja? Ähm also er hat den Beschwerdeknopf gedrückt und das auf Twitter erwähnt und ich glaube, es war noch im.
Am gleichen Tag wurde dieser Fehler behoben. Ähm.
Dann gab's aber noch ein etwas weiter zurückliegenden Fall, der auch sehr viel Öffentlichkeit bekommen hat. Äh das war dieser Fall um. Da hat's nämlich glaube ich.
Tage gedauert äh und damit war quasi, ne, im, in dieser YouTube-Welt sind Tage eben, also Stunden sind ja schon ein Problem.
Tage sind dann eben die ja mehr oder weniger die Vernichtung dieses Inhalts, weil die Leute natürlich auch nur äh oder also weil die Leute in der Regel mehr Kanäle abonniert haben, als sie gucken können und ähm entsprechend.
Wenn dein Inhalt nicht zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung viral geht, dann wird der es nachher erst recht nicht mehr machen, ne. Und welche Möglichkeiten wurden da jetzt,
gegen ergriffen, also ist das jetzt eine stabile Möglichkeit, sich dagegen zu wehren?
Na ja, es ist so mittelmäßig. Also ähm es ist besser als bisher, würde ich sagen. Also um vielleicht nochmal einen etwas aktuelleren Fall zu äh nennen, wo es nicht gut gelaufen ist. Also es gab ähm.
Mehrere Sperrungen von ähm
Videos eines türkischsprachigen YouTube-Kanals, der quasi von türkischen Exil-Journalistin hier aus Deutschland betrieben wird. Das sind irgendwie Leute, die sich mit äh der türkischen Regierung angelegt haben,
und ähm der Staatssender der Türkei, TRT ähm hat,
oder Content ID Strikes gegen solche Videos gesendet, obwohl die teilweise noch nicht mal.
Videomaterial von diesem Fernsehsender verwendet haben. Also das heißt, es spricht doch einiges dafür, dass das gezielt gemacht wurde eben von einem Erdogan, nahen Sender, um eben auch ähm.
Berichterstattung aus YouTube zu entfernen. Ähm das,
finde ich dann schon also nochmal so ein so ein dramatischeren Missbrauchsfall, weil das was jetzt mit Studio einundsiebzig äh da passiert ist, mit äh Thilo Jung
da würden, glaube ich, diese Maßnahmen gegen Missbrauch nichts dran ändern, denn die gelten nur quasi im Wiederholungsfall.
Also wenn eine, ein Rechteinhaber einfach mal nur ein Fehler macht und den Fehler dann auch schnell korrigiert, dann wird sich da wahrscheinlich nichts dran ändern. Aber richtig problematisch ist ja, wenn,
ein vermeintlicher Rechteinhaber systematisch solche äh falschen Cremes macht,
Und da gibt's ja jetzt irgendwie in dem Paragraph achtzehn von dem Vorschlag so verschiedene Maßnahmen. Also erstmal wird gesagt,
dass wenn das wiederholt passiert, dass die Plattform diesen vermeintlichen Rechteinhaber von der dem Uploadfilter ausschließen muss,
wenn YouTube so was macht, dann,
Also die entscheiden ja selber, wer Zugriff auf Content-ID hat und wer nicht und im Fall von diesem türkischen Staatssender jetzt zum Beispiel ähm,
haben wahrscheinlich halt Zugriff auf Content ID, weil sie eben ein großer Rechteinhaber sind als Fernsehsender. Und es ist ja immer so die die,
Vermutungen, die im Hintergrund steht, also wer ein großer Fernsehsender ist, der wird schon,
verantwortungsbewusst mit solchen Tools umgehen und das ist halt offensichtlich nicht immer der Fall. Und ähm in Zukunft, wenn dieses Gesetz umgesetzt wird, haben ja außerdem alle Rechteinhaber das Recht.
Auf Content ID zuzugreifen. Also dann darf die Plattform ja nicht mehr entscheiden, wer darf eigentlich und wer nicht.
Und deshalb, also finde ich's schon sinnvoll, dass da dann jetzt drinsteht, also wenn jemand so wiederholt, falsche macht, dann muss der auch für eine Weile von diesem Upload-Filter ausgeschlossen werden.
Was heißt denn wiederholt, also ist das irgendwie definiert, wie um wie viele Wiederholungen es sich da handeln muss, oder?
Ja, also es ist nicht definiert, was mit wiederholt gemeint ist. Also ich würde behaupten, zweimal falsche Sperrung wäre schon wiederholt,
aber das kommt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen drauf an, ob die Plattform jetzt diesen äh vermeintlichen Rechtsinhaber sperren will oder ob man sie zu ihrem Glück zwingen muss, aber zumindest mal auf dem Papier, sagt das Gesetz,
Plattform ist verpflichtet jemanden zu sperren, der wiederholt solche falschen Claims gemacht.
Daneben gibt's noch den Schadensersatz, also ähm sowohl ich als Nutzerin als auch die Plattform kann eben,
gegen ähm die Quelle von solchen falschen Copyright-Claims auf Schadensersatz klagen. Ähm das Problem dabei ist und das hatten auch die Pink Stinks Leute irgendwie schon ähm also das ist sehr schwer sein kann, als,
Einzelner, Creator, so einen wirtschaftlichen Schaden nachzuweisen, also die äh türkischen Exil-Journalistinnen zum Beispiel, die könnten jetzt vielleicht ähm
Einnahmen, Einbußen bei der Monetarisierung geltend machen, aber das eigentliche Problem ist ja ein Problem der Presse und Meinungsfreiheit
und weniger der wirtschaftliche Schaden, der dadurch entstanden ist. Also es ist besser als nichts, aber ich würde mir eigentlich auch wünschen,
dass es noch ähm stärkere Instrumente äh geben könnte, ähm die in irgendeiner Form halt auch Nutzerinnen,
in die Lage versetzen, wirksam solche falschen Copyright Camps zu unterbinden.
Ist denn überhaupt noch was zu retten? Also was ist denn so deine Eindruck, wie dieser ganze äh Prozess jetzt gerade abläuft? Laufen die jetzt einfach frei und äh lassen sich durch nichts mehr aufhalten oder gibt's da noch Gegenwehr?
Also ich glaube schon, dass man an der einen oder anderen Stelle im Detail noch was verbessern kann. Also konkret, diese hundertsechzig Zeichen sind einfach so absurd niedrig, da glaube ich,
haben die sich einfach auch zu einseitig von den Presseverlagen bequatschen lassen und haben sich über die Folgen keine Gedanken gemacht.
Hundertsechzig Zeichen, so halber Tweet, haben wir schon gesagt
Das ist ja viel zu wenig, um damit irgendwas sinnvolles zu machen. Also, wie gesagt, ähm
ein durchschnittliches Zitat ist mit Sicherheit länger als hundertsechzig Zeichen, das heißt also, wenn jetzt die Bundeskanzlerin eine Rede im Bundestag hält,
und verschiedene Journalistinnen und Journalisten zitieren, dasselbe prägnante Zitat und das hat mehr als hundertsechzig Zeichen,
dann wird halt der Uploadfilter ständig anspringen wegen angeblicher Urberechtsverletzung, obwohl da gar nichts ist. Also da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass man das vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen verbessern kann, aber das Grundproblem,
Also das Upload-Filter halt einfach immer,
Fehler machen werden und legale Nutzung sperren. Das kann jetzt, glaube ich, nur noch der ähm Europäische Gerichtshof wirklich lösen. Denn der muss noch darüber entscheiden, ob Artikel siebzehn überhaupt,
Grundrechten vereinbar ist.
Mhm. Wann tut er das?
Also ähm voraussichtlich äh wird da sein Urteil irgendwann im Herbst fällen, also zu spät für die Umsetzung in Deutschland. Aber es gab schon eine öffentliche Anhörung dazu, die super interessant war,
weil ähm der Europäische Gerichtshof da extrem kluge Fragen gestellt hat. Also er hat zum Beispiel gefragt, macht denn Artikel siebzehn jetzt Uploadfilter verpflichtend?
Und als wären die letzten zwei Jahre nicht passiert.
Behaupten halt, die EU-Institutionen immer noch vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof, also Uploadfilter sind ja nicht verpflichtend, stehen nicht im Text und deshalb kann man es auch anders umsetzen.
Und dann hat der EuGH halt gefragt, ja wie denn anders?
Und dann kamen solche Antworten, wie ja, man könnte äh Fingerprinting machen oder Banken oder Metadatensuche. Äh was halt eigentlich alles nur verschiedene Filtertechnologien sind, aber natürlich keine Alternativen zufiltern.
Und ähm das hat der Generalanwalt dann auch ähm ganz schön kommentiert, der hat dann gefragt, okay also wenn ich in ein Gesetz schreibe
Du musst in zwei Stunden von Brüssel nach Luxemburg reisen, hast du dann wirklich die Wahl, ob du das Auto nimmst oder zu Fuß gehst. Ähm das heißt.
Also die haben das Problem zumindest verstanden,
also eine unglaubliche Erleichterung ist nach Jahren der politischen Debatte mit Leuten, die das Problem entweder nicht verstanden haben oder nicht verstanden wollten.
Das heißt also, der EuGH wird jetzt eine Entscheidung treffen.
Ähm also ich denke mal, sie werden irgendwie zu dem Schluss kommen, dass Artikel siebzehn ohne Upload-Filter nicht geht. Also müssen sie jetzt entscheiden, ist das denn mit der Meinungsfreiheit vereinbar,
Und also wir von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, wir haben eine äh Studie,
gemacht und sind zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass vor allen Dingen, wenn man sich die äh Rechtsprechung des Europäischen Gerichtshofs für Menschenrechte anschaut,
eine solche quasi vor Absperrung von Inhalten, die nicht gerichtlich als illegal eingestuft werden,
eigentlich eine Form von Zensur ist und mit der, mit dem Grundrecht auf Meinungsfreiheit nicht vereinbar ist.
Ob der EuGH zur selben, zum selben Schluss kommen wird, das steht natürlich äh noch in den Sternen,
aber ähm also ich halte dieses Verfahren zumindest nicht für völlig aussichtslos.
Wer hat denn da geklagt?
Hat ausgerechnet, die Regierung von Polen geklagt, deshalb hat auch niemand,
diesen äh dieses Gerichtsverfahren zuerst besonders ernst genommen, weil die haben diese Klage zwei Tage vor der Europawahl zweitausendneunzehn eingereicht und man hatte schon den Eindruck,
dass das vor allen Dingen,
irgendwie ein Werbegag war, um äh irgendwie den Wählerinnen und Wählern sagen zu können, hier wir sind gegen Artikel siebzehn schon immer gewesen und so weiter
die haben sich mit keiner der anderen Regierungen abgesprochen, die auch gegen Artikel siebzehn gestimmt haben, also es gab ja, ich glaube, sieben,
Regierungen, die im Rat dagegen gestimmt haben, aber nur Polen hat quasi im Alleingang diese Klage gemacht.
Und ja, deshalb hat das erstmal niemand so ernst genommen. Die war auch inhaltlich nicht besonders äh dick, also da stand halt einfach drin, Verstoß gegen Meinungsfreiheit, viele andere,
Aspekte waren da drin gar nicht beleuchtet, die vielleicht auch problematisch sind, aber äh glücklicherweise,
betrachtet der Europäische Gerichtshof natürlich nicht, wer da klagt und also was das für Leute sind und,
ob die selber, also was deren eigene Grundrechte äh Bilanz so ist, sondern der europäische Gerichtshof schaut sich halt äh ähm diesen,
Artikel siebzehn.
An, ob er insgesamt mit den Grundrechten vereinbar ist. Das heißt also, der EuGH darf sich sogar dabei mit Grundrechten auseinandersetzen, die Polen gar nicht genannt hat in,
ihrer Klage. Also zum Beispiel Privatsphäre, unternehmerische Freiheit.
Oder andere äh quasi Verstöße gegen europäisches Premiererecht.
Das wäre schon lustig, ne, wenn ausgerechnet Polen.
Also.
Der Meinungsfreiheit sichert.
Wäre extrem absurd, also zumal Polen ja wirklich äußerst merkwürdige Ansichten zu zur Meinungsfreiheit in vielerlei Hinsicht vertritt, also äh ja.
Ja und man durchaus davon ausgehen könnte, dass sie, wenn sie dieses Wikel jetzt haben, das ist natürlich dann auch in dem selben Maße umsetzen, wie das äh vielleicht die Türkei macht oder Ungarn.
Ja, das ist leider immer zu befürchten, also dass wenn so eine Infrastruktur zur Sperrung von Inhalten erstmal da ist, dass die dann natürlich auch genutzt wird äh für,
alle möglichen Zwecke, aber ja, also äh ich glaube, es wird sehr spannend, was der Europäische Gerichtshof dazu zu sagen hat. Ähm sehr interessant, auch was die EU-Kommission sagt, weil die EU-Kommission sagt,
Artikel siebzehn ist Grundrechtskonform, gerade weil da drinsteht, dass legale Inhalte nicht gesperrt werden dürfen.
Und äh die Aufforderung zur Sperrung, da steht nur bestmögliche Anstrengung. Und das heißt also, wenn man beides nicht gleichzeitig erfüllen kann, also einerseits äh bestmögliche Anstrengung,
Urheberrechtsverletzung zu sperren und andererseits legale Inhalte müssen online bleiben, sagt die EU Kommission, dann müssen die Inhalte online bleiben. Denn.
Da steht nix von bestmöglichen Anstrengungen, sondern das ist quasi eine absolutes äh äh Anforderung.
So zu sein. Mhm.
Und das ist natürlich schon interessant, also dass die EU-Kommission im Grunde genommen sagt, es darf nur gesperrt werden, wenn man sich hundertprozentig sicher ist, dass das eine Urheberrechtsverletzung ist.
Und also das finde ich eine Auslegung von Artikel siebzehn, der ich relativ viel abgewinnen kann,
Und diese Anforderungen erfüllt die deutsche Umsetzung nicht. Die versucht eher so zu, so eine Art fifty fifty Abwägung und sagt also bei,
Fünfzehn Sekunden ist es noch hinreichend, wahrscheinlich, dass es legal ist und bei sechzehn Sekunden ist es zu unwahrscheinlich. Das ist natürlich ein anderer Ansatz, als den die EU-Kommission verfolgt.
Aber ähm.
Ja, das ist zumindest das, was sie vor Gericht sagen, weil ich auch interessant finde, also das war dann halt einerseits vor Gericht sagt, nein, nein, es darf überhaupt nicht zur Sperrung legaler Inhalte kommen, während halt in allen Mitgliedsstaaten,
das Gesetz auf 'ne Art und Weise umgesetzt wird, wo es garantiert auch zur Inhalte kommen wird.
Also könnte durchaus sein, dass wir hier in so eine Vorratsdatenspeicherungssituation kommen, wo dann die ganze Zeit immer wieder was beschlossen äh wird und dann kommt der EuGH und sagt so, nee, äh also so war das jetzt nicht gedacht.
Das stimmt und das könnte sogar also äh es gibt noch eine weitere Parallele mit dem Urteil zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung, weil in dem Vorratsdatenspeicherungsurteil hat der EuGH ja auch gesagt.
Dass äh der europäische Gesetzgeber eine zentrale Verantwortung hat, irgendwie Schutzvorkehrungen für die Grundrechte einzuführen,
und es könnte natürlich sein, dass auch ähm Artikel siebzehn genau diese Vorgabe nicht er.
Da steht zwar drin, ja legale Inhalte dürfen nicht gesperrt werden, aber es wird ja mit keinem Wort erklärt, wie das eigentlich funktionieren soll,
und ähm interessanterweise hat der Europäische Gerichtshof auch bei diesem,
bei dieser Anhörung nach der Datenschutzrechtsprechung gefragt, also ob denn dieser, dieses Kriterium,
dass sie in dem Urteil zum Vorrangsdatenspeicherung und auch in einem der Schremsurteile entwickelt haben, dass also der europäische Gesetzgeber zentral für den Schutz der Grundrechte verantwortlich ist, ob das in Artikel siebzehn erfüllt ist,
Also insofern, es könnte durchaus sein, dass am Ende Artikel siebzehn dasselbe Schicksal ereilt, wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Es steht natürlich zu hoffen, dass Artikel siebzehn
das gleiche Schicksal ereilt, wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung äußert doch ein sehr langer Weg. Ich will jetzt nicht hier weiterhin die äh Politikverdrossenheit befördern, aber es ist schon wirklich schwierig bei solchen,
Bei solcher Gesetzgebung, bei solcher solchem Vorgehen von den Parteien irgendwie nicht langsam die Lust zu verlieren, oder?
Ja, also ähm es ist schon sehr frustrierend, wenn man sich überlegt, vor zwei Jahren haben wir darüber gestritten,
Uploadfilter überhaupt sein sollen oder nicht und heute streiten wir darüber, ob der Uploadfilter bei tausend Zeichen oder schon bei hundertsechzig Zeichen sperren soll. Und das ist natürlich eine eine krasse Diskursverschiebung,
und ähm also wenn wir vor zwei Jahren jemand die Tagesschau von letzter Woche gezeigt hätte,
halt irgendwie äh berichtet wurde, ja ähm die Bundeswehr schickt ähm Personal nach Portugal, um die Eindämmung eines.
Furchtbar tödlichen Virus äh äh,
zu zu unterstützen und außerdem streitet der Bundestag über die Sperrung von hundertfünfundzwanzig Kilo weit großen Bildern äh wegen der Urheberrechtsreform, dann hätte ich mich schon ein bisschen gewundert, weil ähm.
Grundsatzfragen, sage ich mal, also die wirklich wichtigen Fragen wollen wir überhaupt so eine Durchsetzung ähm des Rechts durch Algorithmen, die überhaupt nicht mehr gestellt werden, sondern stattdessen wir uns halt wirklich über ähm.
Ja, solche Schwellenwerte streiten.
Oh Mann. Aber du du streitest weiter mit und kümmerst dich drum.
Also ich finde immer noch hundertsechzig Zeichen sind viel zu wenig. Es müssen mindestens hundertsiebzig sein.
Kaum was anderes übrig, oder?
Ja, leider, leider. Gibt's sonst noch irgendwelche positiven Sachen zu berichten in Sachen Urheberrechtsreform?
Ja, also positiv und dann wieder auch nicht so positiv. Also eine positive Sache an der EU-Richtlinie ist ja, dass äh Karikaturen, Parodien und Pastis,
in Zukunft legal sein sollen in Deutschland, also Memes, Remix,
Fan-Fiction, diese ganzen Sachen, die halt super wichtig sind für Internet, Kultur und eigentlich noch nie legal waren in Deutschland, aber die man halt einfach irgendwie so toleriert hat
oder die teilweise irgendwie früher unter die freie Benutzung gefallen sind, das wird ja jetzt alles legalisiert durch die Richtlinie, total super. Ähm.
Wie macht Deutschland das kaputt.
Ja, sie versuchen es zu verschlimmen, bessern, indem sie jetzt irgendwie versuchen, so neue Kriterien zu äh erfinden, was das ist. Also äh konkret steht da jetzt irgendwie drin, also man darf Parodien machen in dem,
Umfang, der durch den besonderen Zweck der Parodie gerechtfertigt ist. Und wenn ich so ein Meme hochlade.
Also diese Frage stellen muss, ist jetzt der Umfang der Entnahme aus einem fremden Werk noch gerechtfertigt für den parodistischen Zweck, dieses dann äh habe ich, glaube ich, schon die Lust verloren,
Und ich halte das auch für Europa rechtswidrig, weil ähm der Europäische Gerichtshof hat schon mal einheitlich definiert, was eine Parodie ist und glücklicherweise sogar auf eine Art und Weise, die ich als Nutzerin verstehe. Also er hat gesagt, es muss humoristisch sein.
Und äh es muss erkennbar sich vom Original unterscheiden. Und das trifft ja auf die allermeisten VEMS zu, total einfach,
Und es gibt also überhaupt keinen Grund, dass sich der deutsche Gesetzgeber da jetzt wieder neue Kriterien aus ausdenkt, die total subjektiv sind und die auch vor allen Dingen für die einfachen Internetnutzerinnen, die das am Ende ja äh irgendwie,
den Alltag erleichtern soll, überhaupt nicht verständlich sind. Also ich weiß nicht, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben und ich hoffe, dass der Bundestag das wieder streicht, weil das einfach Quatsch ist.
Ich sollte ja was Positives bringen.
Das brauchen wir.
Toll.
Ja, wir bleiben, dann würde ich sagen, äh dran und freuen uns, dass du bei diesem Thema bleibst, muss man ja auch nochmal hervorheben. Du
berichte es jetzt regelmäßig zu diesem Thema, aber auch anderen in einer äh Kolumne, die du bei äh heise DE unter Creative Comments Lizenz,
veröffentlichst, die wir deshalb auch glaube ich regelmäßig bei Netzpolitik org genauso lesen können. Ähm.
Genau, die heißt äh Edith Policy und erscheint jeden zweiten Montag.
Und äh das Projekt, wo du grundsätzlich die
EU-Urheberrechtsreform eben auch nicht nur jetzt inhaltlich in der Diskussion, sondern dann vermutlich auch in den juristischen Auseinandersetzungen, verfolgsmäßiger.
Control C bei.
Copyright, ja, aber äh Control C, äh den Witz hast du mir ja letztes Mal schon erklärt, äh mir war gar nicht.
Falsche falsch verstanden habe ich den.
Nein, ich äh ich fand ihn danach fand ich den Namen noch witziger als vorher.
Es hat zwar, genau, wir haben uns damals darüber auseinandergesetzt, dass äh natürlich bei der Namensgebung das Control C im Sinne von Copy äh gemeint ist, aber am ganz alten,
Unix Terminal Control See das Abbrechen eines Prozesses ist, also das ja äh was.
Aber ich find's schön, dass es auch auf der Ebene.
Es macht's nur besser, ja, es macht's nur besser.
Dann kommen wir zum weiteren schönen Thema, dass dass diese Woche das Internet äh beschäftigt hat.
Und zwar äh und nicht nur diese Woche das Internet beschäftigt hat, sondern eigentlich die ja schon seit vielen Jahren äh das Internet beschäftigt. Und es geht äh.
Im Allgemeinen um ich würde mal sagen.
Die Art der Auseinandersetzung, die in diesem Netz stattfindet. Und da haben wir ja schon so ein bisschen Problem. Wir haben uns,
irgendwie dieses Netz mal erhofft und vorgestellt als ein Ort des Austausches von Ideen, der irgendwie der Kommunikation hilft, dem Austausch hilft, uns alle irgendwie klüger, verständnisvoller äh und
einsichtiger macht und so die Demokratie den Austausch der Völker und so weiter.
Ein Werkzeug der Aufklärung.
Ja, genau, fordert, fördert, fordert und somit ein Werkzeug der Aufklärung ist. Und wir stehen jetzt irgendwie.
Vor diesen sozialen Netzwerken, in äh unternehmerischer Hand mit ökonomischen Interessen und einer äh Internetdebattenkultur, die selten ähm.
Gelobt wird. Ja. Und,
Da gibt es natürlich eine ganze Reihe von hm Leuten, aber auch Phänomenen, die dazu,
beitragen. Also ich denke insgesamt, dass die Art wie soziale Netzwerke gestaltet sind, sprich mit Likes und äh ne.
Der im den ermutigenden Einflüssen auf, sage ich mal, polemisierende Inhalte statt äh ausführliche Analysen äh tragen dazu bei.
Dass wir uns im Diskurs äh äh sehr stark verrohen. Äh eventuell auch diese Tatsache, dass unsere Äußerungen im Internet häufig schriftlich,
stattfinden und somit ja ein großer Teil der nonverbalen Kommunikation so ein bisschen fehlt, die gut etwas.
Wie böse oder wie nicht böse oder wie Augen zwinkernd etwas gemeint ist, sodass wir dann relativ häufig einfach nur noch aufeinander losgehen. Das sind irgendwie so ein bisschen die.
Einflüsse dieser Plattform generell auf uns und den Diskurs. Und jetzt gibt's Leute,
die versuchen, sich dessen bewusst zu werden und da vielleicht gegen anzuarbeiten, die irgendwie bemüht sind, ähm tatsächlich.
Diskurse zu versachlichen, indem sie sich sachlich mit Themen auseinandersetzen, ja? Wir wissenschaftlich versuchen,
Erkenntnisse über Pandemie herauszufinden und daraus die sinnvollen und weniger sinnvollen Möglichkeiten und Schritte abzuleiten und es gibt natürlich ein paar Leute, denen genau diese.
Dieser unschöne Diskurs im Netz.
Offenbar irgendwie Freude bereitet. Das sind ja nicht wenige, die kennen wir im Internet, die haben wir auch an der Backe, ne. Die haben wir auch mit äh Logbuch Netzpolitik immer mal wieder irgendwelche Menschen, denen dann, was weiß ich, nicht gefällt
uns hier auseinandersetzen soll, welche Themen wir hier
diskutieren ähm und dann meinen, das müssten sie jetzt irgendwie auf, sage ich mal, eine eine nicht mehr besonders freundliche Art und Weise anbringen.
Und es gibt in Deutschland irgendwie dann auch diesen Diskurs darüber, wie man mit diesem Phänomen umgeht, ja, eine großes Diskussionsthema ist, betrifft diesen, ja, inzwischen auch sehr.
Übermäßig geprägten Begriff der wo es also darum geht ne? Ist das irgendwie in Ordnung wenn man sagt OK bestimmte Leute möchte ich nicht mehr promoten oder nicht und was da nicht alles diskutiert wird
Und jetzt gibt es in diesem ganzen Zusammenhang eine Person.
Schon relativ lange dafür bekannt ist, sagen wir mal nicht unbedingt zu den friedfertigsten
Vertreterin im Netz des Kurs,
zugehören. Es gibt da ja so ein altes Zitat, was ich sehr gerne ähm anführe, wenn wir über über solche Sachen sprechen. Und das lautet.
Event,
also Beispiel, wir haben jetzt hier mit Julia sehr ausführlich über die Idee einer Urheberrechtsreform gesprochen.
Am Rande natürlich auch die Vorkommnisse diskutiert, aber wir haben uns zum Beispiel ähm,
im Rahmen des guten Anstands, am Rahmen, am Riemen gerissen und nicht großartig weiter über Axel Forst diskutiert, weil es sind jetzt nun mal die Ideen des Axel Voss und seiner ähm.
Der und anderer mit denen wir jetzt zu kämpfen haben, mit denen wir uns auseinandersetzen. Wir hätten aber natürlich auch eine Sendung machen können, in der wir die ganze Zeit auf Axel Voss rumgehackt hätten.
Mit der Folge, dass es anzunehmen gewesen wäre, dass einige Leute die Sendung gehört haben, dann auf Twitter den armen Axel Voss wieder fertig machen wollen, der sich inzwischen schon längst mit ganz anderen Themen auseinandersetzt.
Und das ist eine Sache, der wir hier in unseren Sendungen immer versuchen zu folgen, ähm die Kritik.
So sehr wie möglich an den Ideen zu halten und so wenig wie möglich auf Personen zu richten. Wenngleich das natürlich auch manchmal schwer fällt, wenn man in einem Land wohnt, wo der äh ehemalige äh,
Vorsitzende oder der ehemalige Leiter des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz zum Beispiel ein äh bekennender Extrem Rechter ist. Ähm.
Wo wir dann auch teilweise vielleicht von diesem Ziel ein bisschen abweichen. Jetzt gibt's also eine Menschen, der äh seit langer Zeit dieses Internet auch begleitet äh in verschiedenen Blogs, ein,
Privatblog betreibt und früher bei der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung bloggen durfte, dort irgendwann gekanntet wurde.
Und jetzt bei der Welt blockt. Und zwar handelt es sich dabei um einen Menschen namens Rainer Maier, der diese äh Blogbeiträge unter einem pseudonym
veröffentlicht das Pseudonym lautet Donald so. Und was sich relativ klar beobachten lässt, ist.
Dass der sich gerne mit Menschen auseinandersetzt und weniger mit Vorkommnissen oder Ideen. Auch das sei ihm natürlich gegönnt.
Kann man ja machen. Es gibt aber natürlich das Problem, was es da so sich seit Längerem schon so abdeutet, andeutet, dass diese Menschen, mit denen er sich auseinandersetzt,
relativ häufig oder überproportional oft sich danach darüber beklagen ähm von.
Einer bestimmten relativ klar definierten, wahrscheinlich rechtsradikalen Personengruppe äh mit Hass und Morddrogen überzogen zu werden. Und jetzt hat äh die.
Antonia Baum auf Zeit Online mal ein Artikel geschrieben, in dem sehr viele dieser Fälle so ein bisschen zusammen.
Gefasst werden und stellt die Frage, ist der Blogger Alfonso als auch einer Meier dafür verantwortlich, dass Menschen über die er schreibt.
Anschließend von Rechten bedroht werden. Und.
Das finde ich natürlich eine sehr spannende Frage, weil dieser Rainer Meier natürlich jede Verantwortung dafür ablehnt. Und wahrscheinlich hat er auch einen guten.
Ähm ja eine gute Grundlage, die direkte Verantwortung dafür abzulehnen, äh weil,
natürlich nicht von ihm. Diese Morddrohungen ausgehen, sondern,
die von anderen oder mutmaßlich anderen ausgehen, sofern wir einfach mal davon ausgehen, was ich denke, was wir tun können, dass er sich dann nicht mit irgendwelchen Fake-Accounts vielleicht noch dran beteiligen würde. Das kann ich mir eigentlich auch nicht vorstellen.
So, jetzt stellt sich die Frage, ist der Mann dafür verantwortlich oder nicht? Und,
Warum stellt man sich die Frage eigentlich nicht bei jemand anderem? So, wenn man sich mal so Tweets von äh diesem Twitter-Account anschaut, dann irgendwie so,
im Januar zwanzig siebzehn zum Beispiel twittert, was man über die Denunziation des SPD-Werbers Matthias Richel seine Agentur TLG und die SPD wissen sollte.
Ja, also wo er sich,
quasi sehr gezielt ne diese Personen zum Inhalt äh seiner äh Blogbeiträge definiert und somit sie nicht nur am Rande im Rahmen größerer Ideen behandelt oder teilkritisiert, sondern.
Spezifisch sich auf Sie konzentriert oder.
Auch Tweets hier aus dem Januar zwanzig siebzehn. Es wird kein schöner Abend für die Ritzerin, den Matze und die grüne Partei Nafrisans. Ja, so quasi Ankündigung eines Artikels.
Wo er quasi schon so ankündigt, so das wird heute nicht schön. Und äh diese.
Diese Ankündigungen, ja, dass er also jetzt Artikel über Personen macht äh und
dann auch von seinen Followern quasi auch so wirklich ja so ein bisschen begeistert entgegengenommen werden. Ja gib uns was über über die Ritzerin, wen auch immer er damit meint, ich weiß es noch nicht mal, ja? Ähm.
Da muss man sich natürlich schon die Frage stellen, ob man einen solchen Menschen jetzt auch noch die Ehre geben möchte, äh.
In in Springers, im, im, im, im seriösen Teil äh des Springer-Imperiums, nämlich der Welt zu bloggen oder ihn sogar.
Ein, die Jury eines Medienpreises äh zu erheben, der von dem Bundespräsidenten ausgegeben wird,
Gleichzeitig, wenn man jetzt an diesem Menschen selber Kritik übt und man merkt das vielleicht jetzt auch, dass ich mich sehr gewählt ausdrücke, ähm habe mal natürlich,
umgehend irgendwelche äh äh irgendwelche Schreiben von Anwälten an der Backe, weil man
äh angeblich irgendwelche ehrverletzenden Tatsachen, Behauptungen über ihn geäußert hätte. Was übrigens auch der Grund ist, warum sich so selten jemand mal bemüht über diesen Menschen zu schreiben.
Und ich habe mir da in letzter Zeit, ja, viel darüber Gedanken gemacht, wie man überhaupt.
Ähm mit diesem Hass im Internet Phänomen umgehen soll. Und ich bin selber immer so ein bisschen.
Hin und her am Zweifeln. Erstens, bin ich selber verhältnismäßig selten.
Person von so etwas und zweitens komme ich natürlich auch aus einer relativ.
Ja privilegierten Positionen mich damit nicht auseinandersetzen zu müssen, ja? Bin ein bisschen gestehlt im äh Umgang mit diesem Internet und ich bin wahrscheinlich als äh weiser Mann äh mit,
bisschen reich, weiter auch nicht die erste Zielperson für irgendwie äh solche Hassattacken. Aber.
Trotzdem weiß ich nicht, ob es sinnvoll ist, solchen Hassattacken irgendwie mehr Wert beizumessen, als sie verdienen. Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt meine privilegierte Position,
Ich sehe diese ganzen Hassschwelle wirklich eher als ein Zeichen der Schwäche,
Also wenn jemand nicht in der Lage ist, äh so seine Emotionen zu bändigen, im Umgang mit irgendwelchen Themen, äh dann ist das wirklich einfach nur für diese Person peinlich.
Und etwas, wofür man sich nicht entschuldigt, weil man die andere Person verletzt hat, sondern weil man sich selber die Blöße gegeben hat.
Irgendwie die den Boden des guten Geschmacks verloren zu haben. Ja oder wenn man jetzt äh in den Schuhen von Rainer Maier steckt und der Kritik ausgesetzt ist.
Dass man sich die ganze Zeit an Personen abarbeitet, die nur mal ja, leider relativ oft dann auch noch weiblich sind und so ein bestimmtes Muster haben, ja? Wenn man sich so einer Kritik ausgesetzt sieht, dann kann man sagen, okay.
Ja, das tut mir leid, das ist nicht meine Absicht, ne? Oder man kann halt sehr äh.
Man kann halt damit darauf reagieren, indem man im Prinzip weitermacht und dann irgendwie von einer Einschränkung und sonstigen spricht. Und ich denke genau das.
Zeigt halt eigentlich so ein bisschen ja wirklich die Reife, die hier so eine Elena Rosewelt, die ich ja gerade schon zitiert habe.
Eben auch anspricht, ja, so wie wie groß ist dein Geist? Womit setzt du dich überhaupt auseinander? Und ich finde das halt einfach nur.
Peinlich, wenn man so etwas macht und sich an so etwas auch noch ergötzt oder wenn man seit Jahren die, also wirklich einfach mal Fakten belegbare.
Das Fakten belegbare Phänomen hat, dass Menschen, mit denen man sich irgendwie auseinandersetzt, das ist meistens irgendwelche Leute, ja, die.
Keine besondere Reichweite haben oder keine besondere Bedeutung haben, die dann irgendwie zu seinem Zielobjekt werden und danach irgendwie äh im Internet beschimpft werden. Wenn man da jede Verantwortung für ablehnt.
Und nicht sagt, naja, ich könnte ja auch einfach mal versuchen, mich mit Geschehnissen oder Ideen auseinanderzusetzen und.
Vielleicht darauf zu steuern, dass meine Gefolgschaft vielleicht nicht so viele Menschen äh in den Artikeln findet, die sie danach,
fertig macht, ne? Das hat nichts unbedingt mit Verantwortung zu tun, aber vielleicht mit einem, ich will's mal sagen, Verantwortlichkeitsbewusstsein, ja, wenn meine Handlungen,
nicht intendierte Konsequenzen haben, dann versuche ich die doch irgendwie abzustellen. Und ich finde das dann schon so ein bisschen traurig, wenn.
Erstens, ein erwachsener Mann nicht zu dieser Einsicht kommt.
Zweitens, in erwachsener Mann, der nicht zu dieser Einsicht kommt, denn wirklich, ja, von einer einflussreichen medialen Stelle, wie zum Beispiel dem Chefredakteur der Welt, Ulf Poschardt.
Der nun auch nicht dafür bekannt ist.
In gesellschaftlichen Auseinandersetzungen unbedingt den Coming Ground zu suchen.
Sondern eher dafür bekannt ist halt die extremen Positionen irgendwie verschärft darzustellen und äh ja kontroversen äh zu seinem Geschäftsmodell zählt.
Da sollte es doch irgendwo eine Grenze geben.
Dass so jemand vielleicht auch überlegt, so okay, was wie möchte ich eigentlich meine persönliche Rolle und auch die meiner Veröffentlichung, nämlich der Welt.
Im medialen Diskurs sehen. Mir geht's jetzt überhaupt nicht darum, dass äh man Kritik nicht äußern dürfte, denn das macht ausgerechnet diese Sendung hier Lokbuch Netzpolitik seit fast zehn Jahren und dreihundertachtzig Folgen. Wir machen nichts anderes,
und trotzdem schaffen wir es irgendwie ohne dass Leute äh die deren Ideen wir kritisieren,
am Ende mit irgendwelchen Morddrohungen überzogen werden oder dass wir eine ja uns eine.
Massenhafte öffentliche Kritik äh äh ausgesetzt sehen, äh darüber, was für eine Debattenkultur wir hier pflegen würden oder nicht. Und da bin ich irgendwie tatsächlich ein bisschen schockiert.
Dass man hier diese diese Charakterschwäche.
Erstens so stark zur Schau trägt, zweitens das auch noch richtig zu finden scheint, ja und drittens, ja tatsächlich dann.
Auch.
Dem mehr Bedeutung bei ihm ist, als es eigentlich ist, nämlich frustrierte Menschen, die nicht in der Lage sind, eine inhaltliche Debatte zu führen, sondern die aus irgendwelchen, ja, vermutlich charakterlichen Schwächen.
Auf diese Art der Auseinandersetzung Wert legen. Und ich denke einfach nicht, dass dass wir eine eine saubere Kultur der Auseinandersetzung haben, wenn wir sowas nicht einfach nur als ganz, ganz bemitleidenswerte.
Charakterliche Schwäche interpretieren.
Na, ich denke, dass äh die Person das eher als Stärke ansehen, ne. Also wir wir deuten das als Schwäche, aber das ist halt einfach Teil dieser Auseinandersetzung anderer Leute auch einzuschüchtern
und damit halt äh potenzielle Gegenargumente und Überzeugungsleistungen äh abzuwerten.
Ja, also das glaube ich auch, dass äh also es ist ja eine sehr, sehr ähm,
sehr großes Zugeständnis gewisser Weise, wenn man Rainer Meier unterstellt, dass er das vielleicht gar nicht will und nur billigend in Kauf nimmt. Genauso gut kann es äh natürlich sein,
dass er eben genau solche Reaktionen von seinen Lesern,
vielleicht gibt's auch Leserinnen, äh hervorrufen will, weil das natürlich irgendwie auch äh in der Szene seine Reputation stärkt und er ähm,
vielleicht meint daraus Stärke zu beziehen, dass man ihn dann weniger äh gewillt ist, ihn irgendwie öffentlich anzugehen, aber ähm äh nur um nochmal zu unterstreichen, wie,
gefährlich das Ganze ist. Also dass irgendwie Personen äh zum,
zu Angriffen gegen gegen andere sogar zu Morddrohungen und so weiter,
anstacheln dadurch, dass sie sie auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise kritisieren,
das ist ja ein Phänomen, dass es in der extremen rechten irgendwie breiter gibt, also.
Es ist auch äh so unter dem Begriff Dog Whistling bekannt. Und ich glaube, also es gab jetzt relativ wenige, um an Extrembeispiel zu nennen, die gesagt.
Donald Trump hatte keinerlei Verantwortung für den terroristischen Angriff auf das Capitol, weil er ist ja nicht selber ins Capitol,
Also natürlich haben Worte Konsequenzen und auch wenn ähm jemand nicht explizit,
zu ähm Morddrohung, Vergewaltigungsdrogen und so weiter aufruft
natürlich weiß, dass das immer und immer wieder die Konsequenzen von einer bestimmten Art und Weise äh ähm,
Artikeln ist und trotzdem auf diese Art und Weise weitermacht und äh womöglich sogar auf Twitter irgendwie sagt, ha für diese und jene Person wird es jetzt ungemütlich.
Dann ist natürlich klar, dass äh die diese Person das irgendwie mindestens billigend in Kauf nimmt, wenn nicht, äh sogar herbeiführen will. Und ähm.
Leider können halt solchen Worten von Leuten, die dadurch aufgestachelt werden, auch mal Taten folgen. Also ähm es gab diese Kontroverse schon mal, als die ehemalige CDU-Politikerin Erika Steinbach,
auf Twitter, ähm auf eine sehr äh harsche Art und Weise, die,
Asyl und Geflüchtetenpolitik von Walter Lübcke kritisiert hat und.
Wie wie wir wissen, wurde Lübcke letzten Endes von ähm Rechtsextremisten ermordet. Also das heißt, die Personen, die,
die Zielscheibe werden von ja rechten Provokateuren die sich von.
Solchen Kolumnisten wie äh wie äh Rainer Maier aufstacheln lassen,
die befinden sich in realer Gefahr, insofern kann man nicht einfach sagen irgendwie das ist was man einfach irgendwie,
Problem, den man keine Aufmerksamkeit schenken sollte. Aber ich sehe die Verantwortung dafür bei der Welt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass Rainer Maier sich jetzt irgendwie eines Besseren äh ähm
besinnen wird und damit aufhört, das halte ich für für extrem abwegig, aber gerade die Welt, grade der Springer Verlag ähm.
Versucht ja im Moment auch wieder so eine größere Debatte über die äh Macht von Plattformen anzuzetteln und sagt dann auch immer, also die Plattformen sind für das, was dort erscheint, verantwortlich. Aber wie kann man denn das sagen
wenn man als Verlag, wo man ja wirklich die Kontrolle darüber hat, wer dort schreiben darf und wer nicht. Also im Gegensatz zu Facebook
wo man irgendwie grundsätzlich erstmal die Inhalte von allen reinlässt, dass ein Verlag, also der seine,
Kolumisten und seine Journalistinnen gezielt auswählt
sagt, wir haben keine Verantwortung für die Art und Weise, wie Leute auf äh unsere Publikationen reagieren, das finde ich extrem abwegig und scheinheilig,
man gleichzeitig sagt irgendwie, Twitter macht nicht genug gegen Hass im Netz.
Ja, wenn man, das ist ja hier in dem Artikel sehr schön, nochmal zitiert von Antonia Braun, ähm.
Also es anschließt am am Ende des Artikels. Außerdem beklagt Poschert eine Verrohung des Diskurses
die jede Auseinandersetzung im Sinne einer offenen Gesellschaft verunmöglicht. Ja, Entschuldigung, also wenn das das wäre so einer der Gründe
eventuell bald nach ähm Kolumnisten zu suchen, die nicht sehr, sehr eindeutig äh dazu beitragen, ne. Das ist schon sehr ähm,
Kafka Squaster stattfindet.
Das ist natürlich auch so eine Strategie, die man jetzt äh im ganzen Trump Diskurs auch gesehen hat, dass also im Prinzip diese wie soll ich sie sagen, dieser äh politische Bereich, ja, sich vor allem dadurch verteidigt, indem er das, was ihm vorgeworfen wird
äh generell auf die andere Seite abschiebt.
Ja, also in dem Kontext einer, der äh also ein Twitter-Funktionär hat irgendwie mal gesagt, also wenn wir unsere äh Richtlinien gegen Hassrede konsequent durchsetzen würden, dann müssten wir die halbe Republikanische Partei sperren.
Nur sagen kann, ja.
Mach doch! Gute Idee! Könnte man mal drüber nachdenken.
Je
Es ist äh ein äh trauriges äh ein trauriger Umstand, dass wir uns so viel damit auseinandersetzen müssen, wie ja, wirklich dieses wunderbare.
Medium Internet irgendwie nicht, nicht irgendwie sinnvoller verwendet wird.
Aber ist nicht die eigentliche Frage, äh vor der wir jetzt auch stehen, was was ist es eigentlich der Level auf dem hier äh eine
Antwort erfolgen muss. Also dass sich daran was ändern muss, da sind wir uns, glaube ich, einig. Die Frage ist ja nur
Ist das jetzt sozusagen eine gesellschaftliche Reaktion? Ist das äh äh etwas, wo die Gesellschaft reifen und nachliefern muss und das unter Umständen vielleicht auch ein Prozess, der dann irgendwann organisch aus sich selbst heraus entstehen könnte?
Ja? Oder ähm ist es eine rechtliche Frage, ist es ist es sozusagen etwas, wo wir Regeln setzen müssen, weil eben sonst die Sache,
auseinanderläuft.
Also ich sehe die Verantwortung hier in diesem konkreten Fall jetzt erstmal bei der Welt, also die sollten Rainer Meier rausschmeißen.
Das löst natürlich nicht das Problem der Hassrede im Netz,
sondern das ist eher eine Frage der publizistischen Verantwortung an der Stelle und das hat auch erstmal nichts damit zu tun, ob die Inhalte der Kolumne in irgendeiner Form Justiziabel waren, sondern da geht's halt darum,
man äh für solche Reaktionen,
Beiträge eben nachgewiesenermaßen erzeugen, möchte man dafür mitverantwortlich sein, indem man dem weiterhin ein Forum bietet.
Ja gut, aber wir können jetzt mal auch noch ein anderes Beispiel aus den USA aus der letzten Zeit ziehen. Da hatten wir jetzt diese ganze Kampagne von Trump gegen die ähm ja, gegen die Wahrheit,
äh mit der Behauptung, die Wahlen werden ja gefälscht und unter anderem sind sie ja dann massiv vorgegangen gegen ein Unternehmen, ja, was ja dann quasi dem Jahr auch dann direkt Vorwürfe gemacht wurden. Äh
also dieser Hersteller, einer dieser Wahlcomputer, die zum Einsatz kamen, die aber auch nachweislich.
In den Regionen überhaupt zum Einsatz kamen, wo unter Umständen falsche äh Ergebnisse hätten auftauchen können. Und jetzt.
Sind die mit einer Milliardenklage gegen diese News Outlets gekommen, die also die ganze Zeit läuten die Gelegenheit gegeben haben, diese Behauptungen zu wiederholen.
Betrifft hier, äh wie heißen die noch gleich, OAN, ne, das ist so ein so ein hardcore-rechtes Ding und wie heißt gleich noch dieser andere bekloppte Sender? Ähm
unseren generischen Namen. Ich komme jetzt gerade nicht drauf. Und es ist schon wirklich lustig zu sehen, was die da jetzt für ein
Eiertanz aufführen, dass wenn sie jetzt mal doch wieder irgend so einen Luni äh zum Interview bitten
und die dann wieder anfangen, diese Vorwürfe gegen Dominien neu äh anzufachen, wie sie dann sofort dazwischen gehen und sagen so, ja, nee und dann sogar noch vom Blatt irgendwelche Disclaimer ablesen. Ja, das wäre ja jetzt alles schon äh,
festgestellt worden, das kann jetzt nicht sein, wir müssen jetzt im Thema bitte weiterkommen und dann irgendwie ihren Gast sogar noch aus dem Interview rausschmeißen und zum nächsten Thema vorgehen. Also äh an der Stelle äh scheint es ja durchaus zu wirken, ne, weil es eben auch ein rechtliches Mittel gibt,
Ne? Jetzt ist natürlich die Falschbehauptung, ja, die dann sozusagen vor Gericht unter Umständen über mehrere Milliarden Dollar Strafzahlung äh zu entscheiden hat. Noch ein bisschen was
anderes, also diese eher subtilen Vorwürfe mit da ist ja eine Person und die hat ja was gemacht, ne. Nur es ist ja offensichtlich, dass hier der Schutz des Individuums offensichtlich schlechter abgesichert ist, als der Schutz eines Unternehmens.
Ja, das ist sicherlich, hat sicherlich auch damit zu tun, dass so ein Unternehmen leichter einen wirtschaftlichen Schaden an der Stelle äh geltend machen kann.
Aber das stimmt, also äh im Endeffekt bedeutet, dass das ein Unternehmen sich gegen falsch Behauptungen leichter werden kann. Im Zweifelsfall zumindest im US-Rechtssystem.
Aber es wäre wahrscheinlich auch durchaus vorstellbar, äh dass wir so eine Situation auch in Deutschland äh haben können, ne? Also,
würde jetzt, ich will jetzt nicht mit Wahlcomputern kommen, aber wenn sozusagen irgendein äh eine Debatte entfacht oder wer denn jetzt hier woran Schuld ist und dann würde halt so ein Unternehmen mit Falschbehauptungen
belegt werden, was denen dann äh ein Reputationsschaden oder unter Umständen sogar einen konkreten finanziellen Auftragsschaden mit sich ziehen würde, äh dann hätten die natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, dagegen vorzugehen.
Ja, also ich denke, es wäre auf jeden Fall auch schon mal ein Fortschritt, wenn.
Selbst bei eindeutigen Fällen die Strafverfolgung von äh irgendwie so.
Also offensichtlich ein Falschbehauptungen irgendwie erleichtert würde. Aber natürlich gibt's,
eine viel größere Grauzone von Sachen, die irgendwie,
ähm ja nicht so leicht als falsch äh Behauptung identifizierbar sind, die aber natürlich trotzdem irgendwie einen Einfluss auf die öffentliche Meinung haben. Also ich glaube, eine Sache, die in dem äh Bereich.
Sehr interessant ist, also vor allen Dingen, wenn's irgendwie um so politische Manipulationen geht, ist halt auch die Frage des Targeting, also so darf ich als zum Beispiel
verschiedenen Personengruppen, die ich per Micro Targeting ausgewählt habe, ganz unterschiedliche Botschaften mitgeben, also ähm.
Was ja letzten Endes auch irgendwie.
Eine wirkliche Meinungsbildung über die Positionen von Parteien irgendwie erschwert. Ähm das ist ja ein Problem, würde ich sagen, sogar darüber hinaus über die Frage von also wirklichen Versuchen, jemanden von der Wahl,
abzuhalten durch gezielte Falschbehauptungen oder auch die Legitimität von der Wahl in äh.
In Verruf zu bringen. Also ich hoffe, dass wir derartige Probleme bei der Bundestagswahl im Herbst nicht bekommen werden, dass zumindest irgendwie alle.
Die demokratischen Spielregeln noch akzeptieren, was äh ja bei der US-Wahl sicherlich nicht mehr der Fall war.
Naja, also ich würde, ich denke, was wir.
Mein, natürlich bin ich ein Freund der Meinungsfreiheit und ähm ich denke aber auch ehrlich gesagt, dass die hier nicht unbedingt äh in.
Gefahr ist, wenn man die Teilnehmerinnen der Diskussion,
grob zu einer zivilisierten Teilnahme ermutigt. Und äh wenn jemand sieht, was seine äh Äußerungen für Konsequenzen haben, dann muss man da auch einen Lerneffekt.
Erwarten und verlangen. Und das ist bei einem Donald Trump und bei äh republikanischen.
Politikerin genauso wie bei einem Donald Fronso, der übrigens schreibt über sich selber.
Wenn ich selbst die schlechte Nachricht bin, passe ich genau auf, dass ich nicht angreifbar bin. Ich rede dann vorher mit den Verantwortlichen und Juristen.
Alles wasserdicht ist. Je härter der Text,
desto genauer die Vorbereitung. Ja und wer so etwas von sich sagt, ja, der kann ja jetzt nicht behaupten, dass er nicht genau wüsste, was er da.
Ja? Und wenn jemand also ich mein, wenn ich schon dabei bin irgendwas zu schreiben, wo ich sage, okay, dann muss ich nochmal mit mit äh Juristen drüber reden, dann bin ich entweder in dem Bereich, der sich als Investigative Journalistin,
Ja, so eine Sache
sage so, okay, hier krass, da wird's, da fehlt mir ein Stück in der Beweiskette, wie klar, wie nahe darf ich legen, was ich gerade hier sagen möchte? Oder, ne, passiert dann etwas, wo ich äh am Ende abgemahnt werde?
Ähm passiert ja zum Beispiel auch ähm ja ähm investigativen Journalistinnen sehr häufig oder,
nicht sehr häufig, aber regelmäßig, dass sie eben äh damit zu tun haben,
dass sie ja abgemahnt werden, weil irgendeine marginale, nicht hundertprozentig gedeckte Tatsachenbehauptung sich in dem Artikel findet, äh die, die dann eben
justiziabel ist. Ähm allerdings erscheint mir das dann doch und,
irgendwie relativ großer Aufwand zu sein, wenn sage ich mal das Thema deiner Artikel eigentlich nur irgendwelche Personen und deren Twitter-Accounts sind, ne. Also da sieht man ja schon auch,
Form der Auseinandersetzung hier stattfindet. Das ist kein investigativer Journalist, das ist ein Kolumnist und dieser Kolumnist äh arbeitet sich regelmäßig an Menschen ab,
so das. Ist ja ein bisschen was anderes. Also, ich kann abschließend nur sagen.
Steht stünde uns allen ganz gut zu Gesicht. Ja, ein bisschen auch auf die eigene Würde zu achten.
Und einen Vorwurf, den man sich nicht machen lassen möchte, von dem sollte man sich dann eben auch entfernen, ja und ja, jemand, der.
Sich nun mal hauptsächlich mit Personen auseinandersetzen, dann irgendwie in deren Tweets gräbt und dann irgendwie äh ja.
Irgendwie twittert. Freut euch auf heute Abend, wenn meine neue Kolumne rauskommt, dann werden wieder irgendwelche Leute fertig gemacht. Äh da wird's dann irgendwann auch schwer äh also,
zu behaupten, dass man nicht genau wüsste, was passiert, wenn man diese Artikel veröffentlicht.
Na ja, aber ich glaube, das ist auch alles, äh was man dazu sagen muss. Ich denke, man kann nur dazu, man kann nur hoffen, dass sich die Leute das auch immer wieder vor Augen führen, was halt irgendwie Schwäche und Kleingeistigkeit ist und was irgendwie ein Diskurs ist, der die,
voranbringt. So, das mehr können wir dazu auch nicht sagen. Dann
Hatten wir ja mehrere Diskussionen zu äh der App Clubhaus und ich bin sehr froh, dass wir die in dieser Sendung nicht hatten. Aber äh da wir so viel darüber gesprochen haben, müssen wir äh natürlich nochmal ganz kurz berichten.
Hamburger Beauftragte für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit hat jetzt mal.
Auskunftsersuchen an die äh Betreiber.
Gesendet und äh das heißt, er will sich da im Prinzip Sachen erklären lassen. Äh insbesondere, ich zitiere jetzt mal hier von der aus der Veröffentlichung.
So werden die Adressbücher in den Mobil Mobilfunkgeräten von jenen Nutzerinnen und Nutzern, die andere Personen einladen, automatisch ausgelesen und durch die Betreiber
in den USA gespeichert, dadurch geraten Kontaktdaten von zahlreichen Menschen ohne, dass diese überhaupt mit der App
in Kontakt kommen, in fremde Hände, wo sie dann zu Zwecken der Werbung oder Kontaktanfragen weiterverwendet werden können. Die Betreiber.
Speichern nach eigenen Angeben zu Angaben zu dem die Mitschnitte aller in den verschiedenen Räumen geführten Gespräche.
Missbräuche zu verfolgen, ohne dass die näheren Umstände transparent werden.
Anbieter, die sich an europäische Nutzerinnen richten, müssen deren Recht auf Information, Auskunft, Widerspruch und Löschung achten. Gleichzeitig besteht die Pflicht,
technisch organisatorischen Maßnahmen zum Schutz der Daten zu gewährleisten. An all dem bestehen derzeit bei der Klapphaus-App einige Zweifel.
Der Hamburger da beauftragte Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit hat sich daher mit den anderen deutschen Aufsichtsbehörden abgestimmt und hierzu einen Katalog von Fragen,
an die Betreiber in Kalifornien übersandt, um die Einhaltung der europäischen Gesetzgebung zu überprüfen. Ja, das ist schön äh.
Einzig anzumerken ist, das ist natürlich jetzt auch wieder hier so ein äh also zeigt auch so ein bisschen wie
schwach dann doch hier die Möglichkeiten der Durchsetzung sind, ne, dass du jetzt irgendwie Katalog von Fragen sendest als Aufsichtsbehörde und da musst du wahrscheinlich mal gucken, wann sie dir darauf antworten. Und äh ja, bin dann mal.
Gespannt, wie das weitergeht. Aber äh Johannes Kasper ist dran.
Und damit wären wir äh am Ende der Sendung fast, aber denn wir haben nochmal äh lange ist es her, dass wir das getan haben, einen Termin anzukündigen.
Und zwar führt die digitale Gesellschaft der Schweiz am sechsundzwanzigsten und siebenundzwanzigsten Februar,
den vierten Winterkongress durch, da gibt's siebenundzwanzig Vorträge und Workshop in mehreren parallelen Tracks, Veranstaltungen beginnt schon am Freitagabend. Tickets gibt es für zwanzig Franken, das sind ungefähr siebzehn bis achtzehn Euro, je nachdem wie viel.
Readidt noch irgendwie die Franken hoch und runter pokert im Februar zwanzig zweiundzwanzig ist der Winterkongress dann hoffentlich wieder äh.
Also in der roten Fabrik in Zürich. Diesmal ist es natürlich eine vollständige,
Onlineveranstaltungen, die sich daher eben auch für Teilnehmerinnen außerhalb der Schweiz,
Anbietet mehr Infos gibt's unter Winterkongress Punkt CH.
Ja. Da zeigt sich wieder mal, wie selten wir diese Sektion schon gehabt haben, ne?
Was meinst du die Termine Sektion?
Die Termine Sektion. Ja, kam nichts rein.
Ja, weil kommt nix rein. Macht doch mal was, Leute. Minus zehn Grad draußen, Pandemie.
Ja, trefft euch doch mal wieder, Schneeballschlacht. Schneeballschlacht gegen die Pandemie.
Ja
Wenn ihr so eine Schneeballschlacht ankündigt, verstößt ihr dann nicht auch gegen irgendwelche also weiß nicht so, maximal zwei Haushalte in der Schneeballschlacht.
Wir verstoßen dagegen gar nichts. Wir sind nur die Plattform, wir haben nichts.
Ihr seid ja nicht verantwortlich, ja, ist klar.
Wir haben das von von Juristen ausführlich prüfen lassen.
Uns können die gar nix.
Je schärfer unsere Anweisung, desto genauer lassen wir das prüfen. Ich bin hier für nichts verantwortlich, habe das genau prüfen lassen, ja. Schneeballschlacht mit ein Meter fünfzig Abstand ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Zu empfehlen, sonst wird man eingeseift.
Einseifen ist, einseifen geht nicht, einseifen ist verboten. Bei dieses Jahr.
Ja, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung, glaube ich.
Julia, vielen, vielen Dank für deine Beteiligung heute wieder.
Ja, danke euch. Ich schaue jetzt, ob ich die Wohnungstür noch aufkriege oder ob ich komplett eingeschneit.
Also es ist schon echt massiver Schnee da draußen. Das muss ich sagen, da hatten die mit der Wettervorhersage recht.
Das ist unglaublich, ne? Dass Wissenschaftler sich da so äußern und dann passiert das auch genauso in den nächsten zwei, drei Wochen? Hm.
Als nächstes sagen sie noch den Verlauf der Pandemie äh.
So süß. Jetzt war also ich bitte dich.
Na. Weil nicht.
Ja, ich bin dann auch irgendwann wieder für Lockerungen des Schneefalls.
Ja, können wir echt mal wieder langsam lockern.
Zwar schon so lange eingeschneit, es muss das auch ein Ende haben, weil sonst sonst funktionieren die Strandbars einfach gar nicht mehr richtig.
Tim, es hat schon seit einer Stunde nicht mehr geschneit und äh da kann ich ja wohl verlangen, dass es nicht mehr glatt ist draußen.
Stimmt, die Temperaturen liegen nämlich eigentlich schon viel höher.
Ja, ist doch super, also äh oh Mann, er ist aber wirklich, also es ist äh das sowas hatten wir längere Zeit nicht mehr so starken Schneefall.
Ja, ich bin schon ein bisschen enttäuscht eigentlich. Ich wünsche mir eher sowas wie fünf bis zehn Meter Neuschnee jetzt über ganz Deutschland, dass dann einfach mal dieser Lockdown auch so richtig schön in Eis gegossen ist.
Oh Mann, der Lockdown.
So Julia, ich wollte nochmal hier mein abschließendes Lob, weil ich werde ich in letzter Zeit habe ich ja so viel drüber nachgedacht oder was heißt so viel? Wegen dieser ganzen Hassdebatten, über dieses eines der weisesten Zitate. Ich werde nicht müde, das zu zitieren von Elena Rosefeld äh,
So, da denke ich halt auch wirklich dein Engagement jetzt über die Jahre bei diesem Thema zu bleiben und im Prinzip zu sagen, okay, wer das Thema raus ist aus dem Parlament, dann verfolge ich das jetzt in Deutschland weiter. Ähm,
Ich glaube, dass das kann gar nicht genug äh Anerkennung bekommen, so politisch an dem Thema dran zu bleiben.
Und ähm ja, das eben inhaltlich zu diskutieren, das ist die Auseinandersetzung, die wir,
in einer Demokratie brauchen und wahrscheinlich hast du Recht, dass das als Berufspolitikerin wahrscheinlich irgendwann nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ja, danke, also es ist jetzt auch nicht, dass mir das Europaparlament so viel Spaß gemacht hätte, dass ich es total vermissen würde, also äh.
Ist zwar jetzt also ein bisschen äh mehr Action als jetzt im Lockdown könnte ich schon vertragen, aber dass ich nicht mehr irgendwie jeden Monat nach Straßburg pendeln muss, finde ich schon ganz angenehm.
Insofern nicht ganz uneigennütz.
Na toll, jetzt hast du hier unsere Idealisierung kaputt gemacht.
Also nochmal, vielen Dank, äh dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, vielen Dank für dein Engagement, wir
hoffen, dass wir dich bald äh mit neuen und guten Nachrichten auch mal in die Sendung äh holen können, wenn's keine guten Nachrichten sind, ist auch nicht schlimm. Äh unsere Hörerinnen sind ja gewissen Leidensdruck gewohnt.
Ja, wir können ja zum äh EuGH Urteil über Uploadfilter auf jeden Fall nochmal sprechen. Da gibt's bestimmt viel zu diskutieren, egal wie es ausgeht.
Das ist aber frühestens in vier Jahren oder wann wann.
Nee, nee, das ist äh wahrscheinlich noch dieses Jahr, also äh genau einen Termin weiß man nicht, ja. Aber die Stellungnahme des Generalanwalts kommt Ende April und danach dauert's meistens nochmal so drei bis sechs Monate, also.
Okay. Krass, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass das tatsächlich wirklich so zügig geht. Ich hätte gedacht, diese Zeitpläne sind äh auf Eis.
Nee, nee, aber die Klage ist ja auch schon fast zwei Jahre alt. Also irgendwann passiert da was.
Wird die Zeit vergeht.
Ja. Das war's für heute. Wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Bis denn, ciao ciao.
Weil in seiner Heimat auf Rügen Immobilien inzwischen fast unbezahlbar sind, hat Marko sich bei Wismar niedergelassen. Sie brauchen dringend mehr Platz zum produzieren und eigentlich hätten sie den ja auch im alten Kuhstall. Zwei davon
gehören zum Anwesen.
Ich würde gerne halt hier das Dach in Ordnung bringen, einen vernünftigen Estrich machen und dann könnten wir hier halt produzieren. Das Ding ist, ich brauche hier, weil wir sind im Außenbereich,
brauche ich ein eine möchte eine muss eine Umnutzung machen, weil das ist ja hier landwirtschaftliche genutzt, sieht man ja, das sieht man ja, okay? Da brauche ich also eine Umnutzung und die Umnutzung findet auf dem Formular vom Bauantrag statt,
Das heißt also, es ist ein Bauantrag und ein Bauantrag im Außenbereich, da wird das mal abgelehnt. Jetzt soll das Amt neu Kloster den Flächennutzungsplan ändern.
Dann soll die Gemeinde einen Bebauungsplan machen und dann kann ich einen Bauantrag stellen. Verstehst du? Aber die ganzen Planer, die sich natürlich dadrüber freuen über die Regelung, ne, die bezahle ich. Kann ich aber nicht.
Ich meine, ich habe auch keinen Ducaten.
Esel, der Geld scheißt oder was? Wie stellen die sich denn sowas vor? Das ist ganz einfach. Politischer Wille ist nicht da, dass ich hier produzieren kann. Weißt du, was die zu mir sagen? Die sagen zu mir.
Wir wollen die Zersiedelung des ländlichen Raumes aufhalten. Hier oben, Alter,
Guck doch mal raus, wenn du hier rausguckst, wenn du hier rausguckst, da kannst du bis zum Horizont, geht ein Feld und wenn du an dem Horizont stehst, dann kannst du nochmal bis zum Horizont, ist immer nur der gleiche Feld, ist immer noch das gleiche Feld. Wo ist denn da eine Zersiedelung bitte?
Münsterland, meine Frau kommt aus dem Münsterland. Da ist Versiedelung. Ja, da kann man das so sehen, ja. Aber das ist schön, das ist eine schöne äh Landschaft. Und hier ist Agrarwüste.
Und wenn einer kommt und möchte und möchte halt irgendwelche alten Stelle irgendwie nutzen.
Also, tut mir leid. Und dann haben sie mir, dann haben sie mir jetzt einen Verwaltungslotsen zur Seite gestellt. Einen Verwaltung, der mich durch die Stromschnellen, der unteren Verwaltungsbehörde, ey Leute, hört euch doch mal selber, da muss man sich hat man sich also selber zu?
Wenn ich nicht mehr mit Abitur nicht mehr in der Lage bin.
Durch die Stromschnellen, meiner Verwaltung, die ich bezahle, die für mich da ist, mich da selber durchzulavieren. Ja, dann können wir aufhören, da können wir's lassen.
Da kann man es lassen. Also Leute, ich habe Bock was anzupacken. Ich habe Bock, die Welt zu verbessern, aber es muss auch irgendwann muss auch mitmachen.
Ansonsten, ansonsten können wir's, ansonsten können wir's lassen. Ansonsten können wir's lassen. Und jetzt sitzen wir da in einer, in einer äh Produktionshalle, nicht genehmigt, illegal.
Und wir haben und wir haben, wir haben einen Haufen solche, also es sind.
Die wollen unbedingt, dass die Leute vom Land in die Stadt ziehen. Da haben sie mir angeboten, bei Wismar, da war der Saß der Bürgermeister saß hier neben mir.
Da hatten wir einen, da hatten wir einen Termin bei der Landräte.
Nun gehen sie doch nach Wismar, da haben wir auf der grünen Wiese, da ist eine grüne Wiese, da haben wir schön frisches Gewerbegebiet erschlossen, da können sie eine Metallhalle bauen, da kennen wir auch, die können wir, die können wir, können wir einen Flyer geben. Der baut ihnen da die Metalle hin, zack, zack, fertig!
Fördern, fördern wir ihn noch. Nee, will ich nicht. Habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Was mache ich denn dann mit dieser Immobilie? Die zerfällt dann oder was? Wer kommt denn? Wer kommt denn, frage ich mich,
Wer kommt denn? Also kann ich nicht äh kann ich nicht begreifen.
Ich meine, guck mal hier. Guck mal hier. Da musst du dir mal angucken. Da hat sich mal einer hingestellt und hat den Stein, der ist ja so nicht gewachsen. Hat sich hingestellt mit Hammer und Meißen und hat den Stein hier eckig geschlagen. Vor zweihundert Jahren.
Und da baue ich mir eine, da baue ich mir eine Halle auf, eine grüne Wiese aufs Blech. Da muss man schon ein bisschen, bin ich dann irgendwo, wo sind wir denn?
Am sind wir und die Leute, die sowas entscheiden, da sind ja keine Bauingenieure oder so. Das sind Leute, die haben Verwaltung, haben die gelernt. Verwaltung, das sind vom Beruf Verwalten, die verwalten unseren Reichtum.
Im Arsch. Ich meine, es ist halt so. Wir können nicht, also es geht für ein Paar, aber wir können nicht alle mit einem Mac.
Und einem Chai Latte äh in Berlin in einem Coworking Space sitzen und die zehnte Dating App erfinden. Okay? Es gibt auch ein paar Leute, die irgendwas anfassen müssen und sich die Hände schmutzig machen. Ansonsten geht's halt nicht, okay?
Es funktioniert anders nicht.
Wir machen halt Realwirtschaft. Das heißt, wir haben mit mit Produkten, mit, mit Sachen, mit Materie zu tun. Und dafür brauchen wir nur mal Platz. Das ist doch nicht, das kann man doch verstehen, oder nicht?
Das scheiße ich auf die scheiß Glasfaser scheiße ich drauf. Ich brauche Platz!
Brauchen fünf G brauchen wir für die Entwicklung des ländlichen Raumes brauchen wir fünf G. Boah ey da ich kriege einen zu viel.